uh thank you chair uh i've just spoken
to uh council of powell and he's having
trouble with his uh with his broadband
and he's just he's just having to
restart his router and reconnect
so we can expect him shortly thank you
a chair with your permission i'll let
you know who's who's in the meeting
thank you um members in attendance are
counsellors armitage barry cooper
elliott foster liggett
potts bridgeway rouse
ruff and we're expecting councillor
powell momentarily
we also have in the meeting room uh jim
fields then from our legal team
members of the governance team and the
ict team who are supporting this meeting
and phil and adrian from the planning
team
thank you chair thank you as you know we
have a protocol in place for meeting in
this virtual way
which i would now like the meeting
facilitator to read out
thank you chair and members you're in
receipt of the etiquette that we use for
all of our virtual meetings so some of
the key points
um for this meeting if you could and
behave as if you would do if you're
physically within the council chamber
please be aware that the meeting
is being live streamed and recorded um
as for you to speak through the chair
remaining muted when not invited to
speak
um if you do wish to speak a simple
raise of a hand should suffice and the
chair should see you if
she does not and you can write speak
within the chat bar
um i will also have closed captions on
and i'll be able to indicate if i've
seen
that you've indicated to speak and i
will try to communicate that to the
chair
also and when you're speaking if the
first time you do if you would be kind
enough to introduce yourself for example
counselor x
representing y ward um we'll be
conducting voting by roll call on each
application today
please just be mindful of your home
surroundings and appear alone on camera
and to keep yourselves on camera
if you're a member of the committee at
all times thank you chair
thank you we'll move on to the first
item on the agenda as apologies for
absence
thank you chair we have apologies today
from councillors carol huckabee
and tracy reader and um as i mentioned
in the role called councillor heather
liggett is substituting today
for uh councillor huckabee thank you
are there any other apologies for
anybody
no okay item two declarations of
interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interest
and or other interests not already on
their register of interests
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
have we received any declarations of
interest
and receive prior to the meeting chair
do members have any declaration of
interest
thank you item three minutes of the last
meeting
we now have the minutes of our meeting
held on tuesday the 16th of march 2020
are we happy that they are a correct
record and if so
is there a mover
oh my goodness me a second
thank you councillors armitage and
elliott
all those in favor please show their
hands think that's
a unanimous chair thank you
that motion's been carried um the
planning now we'll move on to the
planning applications main business
as you can see we have two applications
each of which is own report marked as
items four and five
i'm happy with this and intend to
consider them in that order
we will also be asked to consider two
provisional tpo preservation orders
these are marked as items seven and
eight again i'm happy to take them in
that order
however before we do this i would like
the clerk to explain for the benefit of
members speak
and the public who are watching on
youtube
how they will be dealt with yes thank
you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the applications
and provisional tpos at the meeting
we will consider the two applications
and the two provisional tpos
in the order that they are set out on
the agenda
the juror will introduce the application
or order
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments
or updates received since the agenda was
issued
the late items agenda supplement has
been published on the council's website
and the link has been sent to members of
the committee
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
the screen showing this presentation
will be shared with those attending the
meeting
they can also be seen on the council's
website through its youtube channel
following on from this the chair will
ask each of the speakers
and the ward members first followed by
objectors
then the applicant to their agent to
speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
using the conferencing facility
the speakers on the provisional tpos
will also have three minutes to speak
there would be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions
if necessary to clarify any points they
have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on an application or an order
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee
and determination by a vote
a note for the speakers once the
application or order
you have come to speak on has been dealt
with you may leave the virtual meeting
room
if you choose to remain then please mute
your microphone
and turn off your camera you will not be
allowed to participate further in the
meeting
from that point as you are aware
this meeting is being live streamed the
council will make a recording for
purposes of preparing the minutes
once the minutes have been approved by
the committee then this recording will
be deleted
please note however that others may also
record the live stream
from the internet thank you chair
thank you we'll move on to the first
application and in line with normal
practice i'm going to ask the planning
officers to tell us about any late
comments reports that they have been
produced
and for the planning manager to give a
brief presentation showing any photos
and plans of the site
the meeting facilitator will share the
presentation on screen
this means that i might find it
difficult to see everyone
therefore i will allow the officers to
complete their presentation
and i ask members to reserve any points
of order
or questions about the process
until the end there'll be plenty of time
for you to ask your questions later
i'm now going to invite the speaker oh
no sorry i'm ahead of myself we'll go to
the planning offices and the first plan
is for
application is for killer marsh which is
ned
forward slash 20 forward zero zero nine
one nine four slash fl
and i believe phil slater you're going
to do it today
that's right chair and thank you chair
um i'd first like to refer
members to the the late comments report
and the comments that we received from
nhs with regards to the section 106
contributions
and as set out in the report the
proposal is for
50 dwellings including seven bungalows
proposed
as affordable housing along with a
commuted sum
for three off-site affordable units we
have the first slide please nikki
thank you this slide is an aerial
photograph of the site and shows
primrose lane to the south uh the route
of the chesterfield canal
is along the western side boundary and
to the northeast is the existing
industrial estate the next slide please
thank you this site shows the red line
application
site boundary and at the top of the
slide you can see the proposed
new mitigation area which is referred to
in the committee report
have the next slide please
this slide shows proposed layout and the
new access road
into the site the layout proposes a mix
of two
three four and five bird units with
on-plot parking
the seven bungalows as affordable
housing are located at the site entrance
the development is generally outward
facing to provide views over the canal
route
and also at the northern end up the next
slide please
this slide shows the proposed access
into the site
we have the next slide please thank you
this is a
visual which shows the site layout and
also
images of the proposed houses that would
overlook the canal route and also the
open space
uh this is a a visual again looking
um from the open space and
back towards the houses
okay that's again some more visuals of
the proposed units and
the bottom one is of the units that are
overlooking the
proposed canal route
these are photos that were submitted by
the agent
and show the western boundary with the
post canal route
again photos from from the agent
looking back towards primrose lane
this is a photo of the proposed access
into the site
it's a photo of showing existing
properties on on primrose lane
photo again of the site entrance
photo looking looking back from the side
entrance towards
primrose lane
it's a photo that shows the um
proposed boundary with the um with the
canal
that area in the foreground is where the
pose open space is located
this is a view looking into the
application site again on the left hand
side you can see the boundary with where
the proposed canal route would be
it's a site another photo from bringing
the application site
the photo from within the application
site
that's the photo they know that sorry um
that's a photo to the northern end of
the site with the on the other side of
the hedge is the proposed canal route
photo looking back towards primrose lane
the area next to the house and in the
in the background is where proposed open
space is located on the right hand side
is where the canary would be
that's another photo but further back
into the site
again similar photo from another angle
it's a photo from the access onto um
primrose lane looking down the hill
apparently from the existing juncture
and look again looking up the hill
these next few photos are going to show
the existing parking arrangements along
primrose lane
let's photo back towards the junction
the next slide please
that shows the site access yeah
that's great thank you chair okay if i
may just at this point just to
confirm to to members that mr grazoner
is down to speak in the pack
mr grizzona can't be with us this
afternoon but just to inform members
that what
he wants to say has been included in the
update report that members have chair
thank you thank you
thank you bill for that i'm now going to
invite the speakers to speak as the
clerk has explained
they will each have three minutes to get
over their points
they will be informed when 30 seconds
remain
as members you can ask them to clarify
any matters that have been
raised but remember your question should
only relate to the points which they
have already made
if the technology fails us we have asked
them to send us in advance a written
statement of their comments
those that we have received have been
included in the agenda supplement
thank you um i believe i've the ward
member down to speak on this
uh councillor steve club
yes thank you chair you're three minutes
steve
okay right okay thank you i am speaking
on behalf of residents regarding the
latest plan applications submitted at
the end of september
proposing to build 50 houses on the land
north of primrose lane
a significant number of residents have
highlighted their concerns regarding
this proposal
they are aware that permissions have
already been granted in 2017
for 30 houses and although remain in
of the view that this was not the right
decision they acknowledged that this
commission has been given in principle
residents however are deeply troubled by
the proposed
identification of the site and that it
is not appropriate for the proposed
number of homes bluntly
30 was bad enough but now residents are
being asked to take
50 on a relatively small road and
accessed by a junction on the brow of
the hill
which is just not appropriate for the
additional traffic movements
from my uh from mine and other
kilometers counsellors conversations
with residents
it is clear that the majority opinion is
that the scale of the new application
is significant and in their view
unacceptable
as it is almost double the amount of new
homes on a greenfield site
and is not in line with the draft local
plan that proposed only 30.
the additional homes with additional
parking for an extra 158
vehicles will place a significant strain
on the infrastructure of the village
beyond that that is already been asked
to do
killer marsh already experienced
significant traffic problems during rush
hour
and the additional cars use would result
from additional 20 homes would make it
even harder for residents to travel
in and out of the village and local
roads would struggle to take this
increase
as i have said the junction is simply
not appropriate for this level of
additional traffic
with many residents noting that the
proposed access to the site
will be detrimental to the free and safe
flow of traffic both on primrose lane
and the adjoining and the adjourning
sheffield road contrary to policies t2
and h12 of the northeast derbyshire
local plan
primrose lane already experienced issues
regarding parking
especially in the mornings and early
afternoons due to nearby
two nearby schools there are times when
vehicles are unable to
traverse through the through the road
due to parked
cars and large vehicles of a large
number of hgvs
30 seconds remain would likely to be
unable to pass due to huge blockages
from local residents it is clear from
the
numerous conversations with residents
that the road network
does not have the capacity to cope with
the increasing properties
for all those reasons and simply because
this represents an unnecessary and
unplanned
densification of the site i would ask
the committee to reject the application
today
thank you do i have any questions
always seems to have got off lightly
thank you
thank you and the next speaker i have
down is elizabeth gene cookson
thank you chair you have three minutes
the width and layout of primrose
primrose lane
and its junction with sheffield road has
not changed for decades
when primrose close was planned in the
mid 1980s
primrose lane was considered not wide
enough for traffic for 28 properties
with one to two vehicles each so the
plans were reduced to 14 properties
which are on primrose clothes
the 2014 application was originally for
40 properties
and was only passed at the third attempt
for 30 properties by one vote i believe
if the lane could not cope with extra
vehicles in the 1980s
and the later application was reduced to
30
where is the logic to say it can now
cope with traffic for 50 properties
with approximately two to four vehicles
each property
the 50 properties in the proposed
development are more than the current
total of
39. the estimated additional 130 to 160
vehicles would more than double the
number of vehicles likely to use the
lane to access sheffield road
without counting the increasing number
of delivery
service and school related vehicles
the site visit on 16th of september 2020
was at the quietest time of the day so
the information
is factually incorrect the visit
should have been between eight and nine
am or 2 45
and 3 45 pm when the situation would
have been very different
due to the number of vehicles accessing
the lane for drop-off
or collection of school children
pictures
were included with my letter of the 13th
of november 2020.
these vehicles often park dangerously
and there have been many many vehicle
collisions either the junction of
sheffield road
or with the close these incidents are
not included in the official statistics
some current residents do not have any
off-road parking
and so they have to park on the road or
partly on the pavement to
allow space for vehicles to try and pass
them
the trip generation data used in the
application
for the 30-50 units in the proposed
estate
may be accurate for journeys within that
estate
it does not take account of all other
vehicle journeys
off onto or off of the estate to
primrose lane
or and the close and going onto
sheffield road
or the proximity of the schools what
30 seconds remain what would the actual
data look like
if it was for all 89 properties so
50 plus the existing 39 plus
resident non-resident vehicle trips
the transport statement suggests that
the worst case scenario is 26 to 27
two-way movements each day but only
within the estate
the worst case scenario already exists
gridlocked twice a day as detailed in my
letter of the 13th of november
mainly with school related vehicles onto
and off of primrose lane
that's time chair thank you thank you
is there any questions
no thank you the next speaker i have
down is claire nundy
thank you chair three minutes when
you're ready
okay the unanimous complaint of all the
residents is the issue of access to this
development
it's our understanding that under the
killer marsh node extension policy
e3 is acknowledged by the red mile on
page 21 of their planning statement
the original approved entrance to this
development site was by the way of
bailey drive
this group would exit onto rotherham
road which is a much safer and easier
access
onto the main highway system and would
not have any disrupted effect on any
residents
our previous objections to the structure
home development
were totally ignored and now it seems
that you can see no problem
with increasing the number of houses to
50.
so can someone please explain why killer
primrose lane
is the better option we can only assume
that it would cost more to develop the
road from daily drive
and therefore reduce the developers
profit
we know from the correspondence that
numerous discussions have taken place
between the planning department
highways agency and red mile but
contrary to what the developer says no
one has approached the residents to
discuss our concerns
especially the highways agency
we are the ones experiencing existing
daily traffic problems which you'll not
find in paper statistics
and guidance notes why were we not
included in these discussions
doesn't our opinion count on the other
hand the developer in their planning
statement
can produce unchallenged statements such
as the residents of primrose lane will
not be unduly affected by the proposal
surely up to 158 extra vehicles using
the
narrow primrose lane will have a major
effect on residents
not to mention months of disruption from
site traffic
there's no conflict between the
development and those properties located
along the unadopted part of primrose
lane
try telling that to the residents who
will be unable to park their cars
outside their homes
surely you can't just plan to use part
of the unadopted road
without consulting with the appropriate
homeowners
it's considered that safe and suitable
access can be achieved for all users of
the site
and the level of activity will not
result in any significant impact on the
local highway network
at peak times it's already chaotic at
the junction of primrose lane
and sheffield road with residence
vehicles
but more so with non-resident vehicles
30 seconds remain
and the addition of the first of 53
two-way movements will
only exacerbate the situation in the
last six months there's been three
recorded accidents on sheffield road
between the broward lockhill and top
side of the school crossing to the east
in conclusion it's mine and the other
residents considered opinion
that primrose lane could not sustain
this proposed development
last time thank you
thank you are there any questions
no thank you and the next speaker i have
now
is julie bennett hello
you have three minutes when you're ready
i am the resident subject of the
application on the grounds that you will
be detrimental to the free and safe flow
of traffic
both on primrose lane and sheffield road
sheffield road is a main highway through
pillowmarsh carrying ever expanding
volumes of traffic
which is getting worse and increasing
numbers using this route to visit the
new glovers world adventure park
the increase in traffic including more
and more hgv vehicles
is regularly causing problems whenever
any form of road obstruction occurs
to the extent that cues are quickly
formed especially at peak times
primrose lane joined sheffield road 150
yards from the infant and junior schools
to the east
and adjacent to the broward block hill
to the west the lane is half made up
with footpaths on either side and the
other side is unadopted
both are narrow made worse with part
cars at peak times there are already
many problems at this junction
including danger exiting onto sheffield
road due to the closeness of lockhill
made worse when vehicles are parked up
and over the brow creating a blind spot
road blockages due to the narrowness of
the lane and the number of part
non-resident vehicles blockages creating
tailbacks east and west of sheffield
road
when vehicles are unable to enter the
lane from left to right
due to cars trying to exit the lane at
the same time
one-way traffic created outside the two
schools when cars are parked on
sheffield road
which again causes tail bikes both east
and west
pedestrians especially on children
maneuvering between the cars
entering and leaving the lane this
application is a major development with
provision for 158 vehicles
generating 53 additional two-way
movements at peak times
which will obviously exacerbate the
existing problems
by the same token the addition of work
vehicles joining the exit
existing chaos at the junction with
sheffield road will seriously affect the
traffic flow through killer marsh
it's our understanding that the highways
agencies should check this application
conforms with policies
t2 and h12 by looking at the existing
situation
and what impact the number of additional
vehicles emanating from this development
would have on the adjoining road network
you would naturally assume that this
would be done at peak times but the
survey was carried out at 11 a.m on a
wednesday morning the quietest time of
day
in addition it was during cove covered
lockdown when there was very little
traffic on the roads
as a result the surveyors apparently
have no objections
they have made this decision having not
witnessed the escalating problems
that the residents experience on a
regular basis
30 seconds remain and therefore a fresh
survey should be carried out thank you
thank you are there any questions
no thank you the next speaker i have on
my list
is the planning consultant michael edgar
mr you have three minutes when you're
ready thank you chair
uh good afternoon my name is michael
edgar from dlp planning and
we are the planning consultants for the
application
as you've heard the principle of
residential development well established
in being a housing allocation and a
previously being granted planning
permission
and to be clear the increased number of
dwellings on site is a result of the
health and safety executive
revising their exemption zones of major
hazards
which is related to the industrial area
to the north it's not to do
with highway capacity uh the 30s drying
capacity referred to in the draft local
plan
is predicated on the previous planning
permission hence that being taken
forward
we've subsequently made representations
to the local plan
under references 10394 10397 to clarify
that
site allocation kl3 should be
amended to reflect this current
application for 50 dwellings
we agree with your officers that uh a
density of 13 dwellings per hectare
which is what you would have at 30
dwellings on this site would be
inefficient
50 dwellings would be obviously a
greater density
and a more efficient use of land which
is in accordance with national planning
policy
in respect to making efficient use of
land but also your draft policy sd12
that seeks to optimize housing densities
particularly in sustainable locations
and in areas with high frequency public
transport
and a number of people have mentioned
issues around the
highways matters the county highways
authority have raised no objection
and to clarify the technical assessments
undertaken
the site visit referred to and this was
not a
site visit to undertake traffic counts
this was a site visit for the
highways consultants to familiarize
themselves with the surroundings
the actual calculations on trip
generation is done from
the trix database now that is an
industry
wide standard database for calculating
likely traffic
it's a modeling tool so it's not
affected by changes and travel patterns
as a result
covered 19 lockdowns and things on along
those lines
to summarize some of the benefits of the
development then we think this is
an efficient residential development on
an allocated housing site
there'll be a mix of housing provided
two three four and five bedroom
properties
there will be bungalows included
chesterfield canal trust
have been engaged throughout the process
and
have commented on it being an
appropriate response to the canal route
frontage
30 seconds remain there will be a safe
access provided
20 affordable housing provision will be
made with a combination of seven
affordable houses
as bungalows on site and a financial
contribution topping up the remainder
as well off-site play provision
maintenance so i
summarized by saying we welcome the
recommendation and thank you for your
time today
thank you could i just ask one question
of you
the two uh properties are they all
bungalows
that's a good question
i believe they may be just double
checking that i'm trying to find a
stretch of accommodation
yes they are thank you so i'm just a bit
concerned we had nice pictures of all
the uh
large properties but there's nothing
regarding the smaller ones i just
wondered what they
uh would appear like i know bungalows
indeed
thank you are there any other questions
counselor shipment then counselor parts
cheers chair
um hi michael i wonder if you could um
just clarify you know are you saying
that some rules have changed so
now you're able to build more houses
does that cost the
um buffer zone from the actual
source of the dangerous whatever is
chemical substances whatever is reduced
and therefore you can build further
closer to it is that what you were
saying
yeah it's it's it's slightly um
different than that it's actually the
number
of houses that you can have within
different zones
and it's the health and safety executive
have reviewed their
legislation in that regard and their
guidance and so they've changed the
number of
houses you can have in an area at risk
but they have also reviewed
boundary area as well which is what's
reduced it
thank you councillor potts
good afternoon michael um my question is
relating to
0.4.3 on page 15. um you've talked about
the transport statement that's been
submitted to support the development
proposals
um it does say that it does not include
a capacity
assessment of the access um
why hasn't that been done is my first
question and
if it hasn't been done how can anybody
possibly draw the conclusion that
capacity is unlikely to be an issue
on this development thank you
i'm not a transport planner but my
understanding is
that you wouldn't usually have
that kind of level of detail for a
scheme of this size uh
similarly with the um position being
that 32 irons had been
consented on the site it was looking at
an uplift of 20 additional houses
and so again there was a baseline of
data that was being used by the
consultant in that guard
and the highways county highways
authority
would potentially ask for such
information
if they considered it required it did
not come up in
discussions with them as being a
requirement in this case
you could say it's just an additional
20. um i could say it's
almost double um depends which way
you're looking at it i suppose but thank
you for your response
thank you councillor foster uh thank you
chair uh
council foster member for call austin uh
on that last issue just to bring some uh
clarity on this um and it is uh
i'm happy to have an answer from mr
edgar uh but under the adopted local
plan
under t2 7.23
it states this is the one we follow
right now
where a proposed development would
generate a significant travel movements
okay uh generate significant travel
movements or travel impact
the council will require developers to
submit a transport assessment showing
the impact of their proposals on the
existing highway network and setting out
the measures to offset
any adverse impact including where
appropriate
through the implementation of a travel
plan what that means is
is that we expect that capacity
assessment to be done that's what it
means and i know you
you don't specialize yourself mr edgar
in this and you may be looking at other
issues around
this application but that's what we're
working to and that's what all members
here are working to and it's something
i'm going to put to our offices shortly
uh that's seven point two seven point
two three under t2
so it we expect that and it's not the
county administration issue it's that
this is what we expect
as a planning authority now respond
sorry to respond yes yes you certainly
thank you
my understanding is that that has been
undertaken
a transport statement has been provided
i believe what i was previously being
asked about
was very specifically a junction
assessment
there is that is a level of detail that
we would not usually see
the development of this scale i
appreciate what you're saying counselor
and i entirely agree a transport
statement is required and has been
provided
just to be clear so sorry
it is uh it is clear but like uh council
pots pointed out it doesn't
include a capacity assessment and that
is the issue that's bothering
uh people here that's bothering people
that object to it and bothering i know
already other councils
that is the issue we're looking at
thank you are there any further
questions
thank you mr ecker thank you
okay we'll move on to the next i'm going
to now ask
you you have the opportunity to put
questions to the planning manager and
other officers
about the application again i would like
to keep this part about
proceedings focused on getting clarity
about any
points that you are not sure of once we
have done this we can then have a
discussion about the application based
on
all we have heard and read for that
reason members i would be grateful if
you could not move any motions at this
stage
let's wait until we've all had a chance
to make our assessments
and to ensure that this happens and
avoid any confusion
i've once again asked the clerk to
highlight this point if anyone indicates
that they wish to move a motion
before i have said that would happen and
be prepared to take them
the same rules apply please mute your
mics unless you wish to speak
alan if you'd like to uh take us through
this
uh it doesn't appear as if there's any
questions for the officers
is that right members oh yes i've got
council advantage councillor shipman
and counselor barry we'll start with
councillor barry
yeah adrian um under 4.3
where it talks about the transport
statement being submitted
it relates to two-way trips during the
morning and the evening
how have we come to that seen as the
applications first and foremost for 50
houses
the size of these houses i would say
would say you've got children
going to school so there's going to be i
would have thought more than the 30 that
is on this statement
and also in our local plan am i right in
saying that
that we have approved 30 houses in the
local plan
and the fact that the local plan is due
to be adopted any time
should be paid significant notice off
just on those two points in terms of the
32-way trips that's what the submitted
transport statement has
set out as their assessment chair and
members will note at
paragraph 4.3 that the highway authority
is satisfied by that
assessment in this case in making its
recommendation just to come back
to the point that council fosters just
made in terms of the
area 7.23 of your extant local plan
you've heard mr edgar's
advice on that particular element i i'm
minded to agree with him in that the
paragraph requires
a transport assessment to be done and
that has been submitted to us
and assessed by the highway authority
just
in terms of the 30 houses in the
publication draft local plan chair the
wording
is that it would be appropriate for
approximately 30 dwellings
and that doesn't even if the local plan
were to say 30
it wouldn't stop members accepting a
higher number if that was deemed
appropriate bearing it
taking into account all matters so the
fact is in excess of 30
there's a number set out approximately
in your
publication draft local plan doesn't in
the view of officers stop you
considering and accepting a higher
number
of dwellings on this site if you believe
it's acceptable
thank you councillor shipman
thank you chair um who's the officer
adrian are you answering the questions
on this one
are we saying that this amount of money
that we're being offered in lieu would
build us three hours elsewhere in the
district
um or what will this money be used on so
if you're conscious that
when applications come in the affordable
housing numbers seem to
get lower and lower and this seems to be
other ways
how they're wriggling out of not
providing them um
so i'm just wondering is this money
going to build more affordable houses or
what's where is it going how are you
this figure
i can answer that the figures um is
provided by our housing
housing strategy officers so there's
providing the seven units on site
and then they're providing the
additional monies towards
three units to be provided off-site so
it would make a total contribution of 20
which is a mix of on and off size so
they are providing the 20
affordable
yes thank you councillor armitage
yeah it's a question to adrian uh
there's been
i remember last time uh great emphasis
was put on the
fact that it was uh the site was located
within
a hazardous installation zone
and it was uh it's indicated on the
draft local plan
and uh could you tell us
uh that what these chemicals
are that are supposed to be uh
emitted because i remember at the time
they were mentioned and i did some
background
research as to what these chemicals were
and quite frankly uh the information
which i received
was quite frightening in the fact that
some of them
they didn't even know what they would
smell like because
if you took a whiff of them you would be
dead and that's the sort of hazardous
chemicals
that are on this site now you mentioned
that
there is a a portion of the northern
part of this site uh is within uh
perhaps is is in this zone could you
point out
where exactly it is in relation to the
houses now we've had it
i've seen the the plan and it just shows
the thing but it doesn't show
how many houses are there within this
site and you also
mentioned which chemicals there were
last time but we've had no
nothing back that way and yesterday when
you were going through
you said that hsa
declared it and there wasn't a problem
there with it so
could you please explain
i can i can come with you if you want to
aid um council armitage it's referred to
it paragraph 7.36 in in the report
where the um and 7.37 where the
health and safety executive have
confirmed that the site doesn't lie
within
within the zone so there was no
requirement for them to provide a
consultation comment
just in addition to that care just to
point out that
again you heard mr edgar earlier on
consider the the issue of the
consultation zones and
he was absolutely right that when the
previous application was being
considered for
30 there was a different consultation
zone area which only permitted
the 30 houses on this site within that
zone
following determination of that
application the hsc
revised their consultation zoned and
they're
shown on the plan at the top of page 12
in the
papers chair and just to be clear that
the
dwellings now proposed on this site
don't fall within
that area and so as phil has just
advised you there's no need for the
hse to provide any comment or provide
any advice on this because it falls
outside those consultation zones
yes but this is all all very well
but it's uh dependent on the prevailing
winds
now i understand that at this
capital site there is a wind sock now
why do they have a wind sock there
i can remember that it was noted
last time about this windsock so these
chemicals
are gaseous at local ambient at normal
temperatures
so it's just a question of which way the
wind's blowing whether or not
this site this uh actual uh
plan will be just defunct
would you agree i just uh
if if i may just reiterate the comments
i made a few minutes ago the
advice we're getting from the proper
body on this issue the
hse have not raised any objections to
the
scheme the site falls outside the
control consultation zone
the hsc is phil was just advised members
i would advise members to to be very
careful how much weight
they place on the issue of the you're
joining the only site bearing in mind
that all the houses
which are proposed lay outside the
consultation zones
are set down by the hse and the hsc
their comments to us have not raised any
objection to the scheme
thank you chair uh question for you the
mr kirk and mr slater
and it's going back to um
t2 of the adopted extent local plan uh
and looking at
7.23 again i'd like to have my fears
and concerns and um the concerns of
the rest of the community here um put to
bed on this
uh when we look at what he just says as
as i've already gone through
with um with the consultant mr edgar
it says again to repeat where a proposed
development would have generate
significant travel movements now we know
this would
there's 50 houses being built here and
we know there's going to be significant
travel movements that's accepted
we then said that the council will
require developers to submit a transport
assessment next
says a transport assessment
we then go back to four point a capacity
assessment
so we've only got a transport statement
stating what he states those
32-way trips uh and an initial
uh comments asked for from from county
highways for 30 dwellings that's all we
have
what we don't have is what we require
under our current
um local plan is a transport assessment
and that's exactly what people's
concerns are in this case
it's about the weight of the traffic the
cumulative effect
of the traffic and the impact it's going
to have on local amenities
the environment and local road users
and we don't have that assessment so
it's a major concern of mine
uh so question to either mr kirkham
misses later
how can we haven't asked for a proper
transport assessment and yet we've ex uh
we've accepted a transport statement
without this uh without this assessment
that's my con's turn
i can try and answer that as council of
foster and they've submitted a 36-page
transport statement so um
in my my opinion the transport statement
and transport assessment are essentially
one of the same thing um the third six
page document is
is a detailed document that we've
consoled the hardware through our
children
and they haven't raised any objections
to it
that's a good point if you can come back
chair that's mr slater you're right
a 36 page document it may well be long
and there might be a lot of paper there
but that was submitted to the county
highway and that's based on 30 dwellings
it's not based on 50 dwellings that's
the important point
thank you councillor [ __ ] but chair
could have still he could have heard
from mr slater on that point
oh yep sorry if i could
come back to the counter on that i'll
just just uh have a look through the
transport statement
and see whether it refers to 50
dwellings or or 30 dwellings
just while phil was doing that chair the
the transport statement has set out at
paragraph 4.3 talks about
generating 32-way trips during the
morning and evening peak
but subject to phil's confirmation share
that
doesn't necessarily equate with um
30 dwellings but i'm sure phil will come
back in a second
yes yeah chair if it's possible i've
just got a question for adrian while
phil was looking for that can i add it
to my list then because i've got
councillor [ __ ] in front of you and
councilman harry
apologies thank you it's a question
question for adrian um there is a
formula
and if i'm right i think we're talking
300 vehicle movements in 24 hours
as we discussed in the site visit
yesterday the thumb that
i've always been advised that the
highway authority would take into
account in making their assessment is
as council they get said six vehicle
movements
per property per 24-hour period of which
15 of those would be in the peak hours
and even if you take that calculation
which is in excess of what
transport to state is setting out and
which the higher authority
commented specifically on in this
instance that is during the the peak
hour
45 traffic movements during that
hour which as members will be aware is
equating to less than one a minute so
even if that were the case members need
to assess whether that would
overload the junction and or bring a
serious adverse impact to highway safety
and so his officers we would take the
view bearing mind what the county
highway authority said
that it wouldn't even at that level of
vehicle movement you've heard a lot this
afternoon about
how people apart the school pick up and
drop off times
yes they are issues across the district
across the country
but bear in mind they are limited times
of the day
my view would be to advise members not
to put
overriding weight on those two
particular
small elements of the 24 hour clock
uh chair from a um the the transport
statement
is is in relation to 50 dwellings not
not to 30 dwellings
thank you
are you happy with that uh councillor
foster thank you
moving on counselor barry
yeah um i don't know whether be adrian
or phil
that would answer this one but i'm i'm
still with uh councillor armitage in
as much as the the 7.36
and about the hazardous uh area around
there
the reason we came to the the um
sum of 30 houses in the previous thing
was purely to do with
with those areas that were marked as
being
hazardous for housing as far as i'm
aware there's been no
chemical cleanup at all on that site
since we passed the last planning
application
and if that's the case what evidence and
how
of the hse come to the conclusion that
it is now safe
um to put houses there when you know as
far as where it were
there's been no cleaning taken place and
the the 7.36 and 7.37 don't actually say
how they have come to that conclusion so
i wonder if you could help us on that
one
carol i'll start and phil's got
something to add i'm sure he will
but the story of the exclusion zones as
council barry mary core was that as i've
mentioned earlier on that
when the previous application was
considered
the exclusion zones weren't in the
location that they are now
and they would commit or did permit the
hse to accept
up to 30 dwellings on this site
that was the situation then but
subsequently the hse reviewed their
exclusion zones and have redrawn them as
per
those set out in the officer report and
recreated at age 27
and so the site now lies outside those
exclusion zones so the hse have
concluded
that there is no adverse impact in terms
of their own interests
the development of a greater number of
houses would be appropriate
as far as officers are concerned we take
that device on its face
we're not chemical engineers or
health and safety experts and we rely on
the specific
and the expertise of the hse in
addressing that issue chair
i hear members concerns about that
but into the ultimate share of members
were to
determine to refuse the application on
that grounds and we were tested
on evidence of an appeal as far as i'm
aware chair there is no
evidence contrary to what the hsc have
set out from their consultation reply to
us
and i think we will be devoid of being
able to
defend that reason unless members are
aware
of other information that officers are
going to wear when preparing our report
thank you councillor elliot then
councillor foster
and councillor army thanks chair
councillor elliot branson and walton
wood
uh adrian it's just a quick question for
yourself um
we heard uh councillor clough speak
about the densification of the project
uh and and i'm just looking at a bullet
point i would assume it's five
five nine uh and it refers to the local
plan
and and i'm asking why if 40 dwellings
uh were unacceptable on 2.8 hectares
back in 14 yr 50 now allowed on us
on a smaller footprint only if you could
just give us a bit of help with that one
please
share i asked casually just to remind me
of the paragraph that he referred
to please uh i'm on page 23 adrian
the of the um
the paperwork and it's the fourth bullet
point
up at the top of the page it's just
about property density
it's just with councillor club bringing
up densification
i just wondered if you could give us a
bit of a heads up on that one why
if it was unacceptable back in 14 for a
lesser amount on a bigger
footprint we're now looking at 50 on a
smaller footprint
care i know um phil was able to advise
members on the specific area of the
report where that's referred to but
i am i'm slightly confused sharing that
the comment that's made that
catalytic refers to is comment made in
representations to the council
and the application in 2014
was for 30 dwelling houses and i need to
check
exactly why that application was refused
but my recollection was and that was
based on
highway safety grounds but i will just
check that if i can ask
phil at the same time chair just to
advise members wherein the report the
element of identification and density is
addressed
councillor foster do you want to come in
whilst we're waiting thank you chad will
do
uh i don't think this will be a hard one
page 13 right at the top
2.7 a total of 158 car parking spaces
will be provided as part of the scheme
and it
looks like we're counting spaces and
garages where people park the cars
if people do that so that's 158 car
parking spaces
um 43 of which are inside people's
carriages which leaves us 115
out of those 115 or any of those 115
spaces
on people's drives so how many of those
are on people's drive so could we take
that number off
as well do we have those details please
it'll give us an idea what the what
how the the estate will look what the
intent is
all the parking is um is on plot parking
so it's either
it's either a driveway or or a garage is
it thank you so none of that is counted
on the road or anything like that
outside anybody's
in that video no it's all on plot
parking
thank you appreciate it just if i
can come back to counter elliot and
share
i can refine the um the 1940s
sorry the 2014 refusal notice that was
refused on two grounds chair first
ground was that the dump to the site
didn't provide for the restoration of
the chesterfield canal
failed to provide links between the
canal and the countryside wouldn't then
result in any employment provision
as per the north establish a local plan
and secondly share that it would fail to
provide a mix of housing
with only a limited opportunity to
provide affordable housing
not to accommodate the required size
type tenure and range of housing
required
so it wasn't on i would say to grow so
my apologies there but it was on those
two grounds chair
so not specifically on the the concern
perhaps that councilor elliot has
so i'd like to say the absolute numbers
thank you adrian it was just that i read
it on one of their bullet points and i
just wanted clarification on it but
that's fine thank you
thank you councillor armitage
yeah thank you chair it's just uh again
it's it's the chemicals
uh i mean last time we had a number of
chemicals
that were in the area
but you decided not to put them uh make
mention of them
and you know we
is taking the hse uh
uh uh what they've said has been
uh okay but without the actual
uh type of chemicals we don't even know
if the
gaseous at standard temperature and
pressure
and uh you know
again it's dependent on the prevailing
wind
to a lot of these but anyway i thought
we should have had a detailed uh
list of what were likely to be
handled at that site whether or not the
hse
said it's safe or not
we had it time and you know
we haven't done it this time well that i
mean that that would be my own
i've written the report but um
essentially the
health and safety executive said there
was no requirement for them to be
consulted
i'm not a chemist so a list a list of
chemicals
is is just going to confuse me right in
the report
and you know the health and safety are
executive are our secretary council t on
on these sort of matters
and so when they come back and say
there's no requirement for them to be
consulted
that that really is is as much as we can
do on the matter
well i'd rather have seen it then i
could have checked up what they were
because i have access uh to be able to
find out
somebody who is highly qualified anyway
that's that
thank you and councillor barry nixon and
i think we'll wrap it up and move on to
our discussion
yeah adrian i'm i'm sorry to go on about
this chemical thing and i know
uh council armitage as well but i'm
really concerned that
the last time with this came in front of
planning the chemicals
were a big issue now i accept the fact
that the hsc have changed the boundaries
and they're saying it's all right now
but there was all sorts put in place
last time like leaflets being put
through houses if the wind was blown in
the wrong direction and
various other bits and bobs that came to
light
i find it very strange that those two
short paragraphs
do not address any of the concerns that
we had
last time and because there's been no
cleaning of that site
uh chemical cleaning of that site i'm
i'm
really struggling to see how the hsc
have come
forward to say there isn't a problem
there now um
have the hsc giving you a more detailed
uh report than what's actually put in
here or not because if it hasn't then
i think if if we were to say that this
was part of a reason to refuse then we'd
have to have that information before us
uh and that those comments to the report
are
pretty much uh debating what the um what
the health and safety
have said to us generally
i'm in danger of repeating myself here
but and i know
the concern expressed by councillors
armitage and barry
i'm not seeking to diminish those
concerns chair but
the situation in 2014 was
and subsequently was a different
situation than we are faced as planners
now
in the current situation on the basis of
the current information and
in terms of your publication draft local
plan which
i agree with councillor barry you should
be placing
considerable weight on now the site of
the house is light outside the
consultation zone so
it is not surprising towards your
office's chair that the hsc have come
back with the comments that they have
lies outside the consultation zone so
the area
wherein they would be concerned about
development and so they're not concerned
about
advising us that we may grant plenty
permission on on the site so
we aren't able to add any more chair i
hear what members say but the hse
don't have any concerns and my advice to
members would be
to be very careful how much weight you
place on this issue
bearing in mind the designation in the
publication draft local plan and the
comments of the hse
thank you thank you to the officers for
all the responses and before we move on
to
our debate um just like to make sure
that we're all aware of
the regards to emotions i'm going to ask
alan to
take us through this
ah yes thank you chair uh please bear in
mind members
that a motion must be moved and seconded
uh before a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded
then that amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
member of
against officer recommendations should
comprise the relevant planning issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations
fails or in other words it is not passed
that doesn't mean to say that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion
in favor of the recommendations or
another course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
in terms of the timing of the motions
these should be moved and seconded
after the committee has heard read and
discussed the evidence before
it the chair will indicate when this
point has been reached
and will then invite members to place
motions before the committee
members will be reminded of this by the
clerk if they wish to propose a motion
before then
thank you chair thank you um again
just to remind us all that uh we can
refrain from making any motions till
we've concluded any discussions and i'm
going to open the floor
council armitage
yes thank you chair it seems to me that
uh the only safe option we have here
is the fact that uh it goes against the
draft local plan which proposes only
30 of this site
the question about the
highway safety i mean the development
would add more traffic
to a highly populated cul-de-sac
and it exits onto a busy main road and
it's close to a school
but having said that the highway
authority seemed to
go along with it because as usual
they uh never got they uh
they don't never look at the cumulative
effect
of the houses which are already there
and
uh you know on that i i think it would
be dangerous to use that as a reason
and the only uh thing as i can see is
the fact that it's not in line with the
draft local plan
which have proposed only 30
and i'm not in favor of this particular
thing because
i can't propose a motion just at the
moment can i
could i be right certainly not
right
increase is i know 20 hours doesn't
sound a lot more
when it's 20 more out of a
an area that should have had 30 in
you're talking you know a
significant percentage increase for that
area
that's definitely one that it can refuse
on i actually also
it really annoys me that we keep
describing these developments as
sustainable
in order for it to be sustainable it
needs to have and it's in here somewhere
that we've wrote it down
there's three aspects to it some of that
economical social and environmental well
of course and you know any development
meets the social aspect of it
it's a residential development but
the excuses being given why this is a
sustainable one is
also what every other development means
just because you're building houses
doesn't mean you're creating jobs in the
local area
it's what it means by economical
benefits
is that the development itself provides
jobs once it's built
that that itself can then be sustainable
and provide
employment for people that are living on
the last day it's not sustainable just
to say you're
creating jobs just because you've got
some builders in and you may be a local
carpenter
that's that's not what makes it a
sustainable development
so i think that that's another area as
well that we can impose this on
and again i mean i i don't know if this
this can be confirmed by other planning
officers but uh what the agent said
in that the assessment that they've
created their statement on
was done by someone pressing a button on
a modeler
well that doesn't take any of the local
um
situation into account that's just
taking some national model what they're
applying in different areas
and um different demographics but
that's not what shows a reality of the
situation
and i think that really that serious
needs to be included in a reason why
we're rejecting it if it's not
then anybody that's if it does go
through appeal anybody that's trying to
use that as an argument won't be able to
use that
um item when they're trying to argue an
appeal so i think
those three in my opinion are reasons
why i think we should
reject this application i mean if it
come back with 30 then
we could have a different conversation
but i think in its current state
i think we're seriously struggling to
really approve an increase of whatever
nearly 70 on the original one that was
approved five years ago
thanks chair thank you any other
comments
oh councillor barry yeah i think
following on from council hermitage the
fact that this is
what we've got in our draft local plan i
think we should be keeping to that i
don't think we should be moving out of
it
the other concern is we never seem to
have addressed the issue that there is a
possible
other entrance for this um this building
estate and then my other concerns are
about it these are high class houses
um and more than likely going to attract
people from outside of the area
into into it it's not going to
necessarily be local people that could
afford those
houses so i think all that needs to be
taken into consideration and i think
i i still stand by the original
application for 30 houses that's a site
that could take
30 houses there's still going to be a
transport issue even with those 30
houses
and i think to near enough double it
would would be wrong
um i mean that the transport it might
not be just school times there's
there's other times during the day
there's people going in and out of work
you know people work all different hours
and the more people you've got in there
then the more traffic you've got coming
in and out
so the fact that egg you've not looked
at the other angle of whether we could
put a
another road into it or not and and b
the fact our local plan is due to be
adopted any time that
specifies 30 houses i think we need to
be sticking with that
at least if we're going to have to pass
anything that should be what goes
nothing else
thank you does anyone else want any
other comment
etc before i move to a councillor parts
councillor parks yeah thank you chair um
for me this is all about the safety
aspects highway safety and
to be honest i don't put much weight on
the fact that highways haven't put any
objections in because how frequently do
they they just don't
um i get the point about the
developments driving to make efficient
use of the land
regarding the minimum density but i
don't feel that we can allow that to
happen at any cost
and the nfppf states that rejection is
permissible if the development has an
impact on safety and i believe this
certainly does
both from a pedestrian and a vehicle
point of view
um 158 extra vehicles on on
on a lane like primrose lane um could
have a serious
impact on safety um
not to go too much overall ground but um
the extra traffic will
access and leave the development via
criminals lane elena already congested
by a resident vehicle and school drop
off
and collection um it's only got a
partial
pavement on one side of the road where
pop cars already park on the pavements
um and it feeds onto a busy sheffield
road with its restricted view concerning
traffic at the brow of the hill
um this is contrary to teach two of the
local plan
um and i believe
while we're also talking about adrian
made reference to the fact that
the seriousness of the congestion is
mainly at school
collection and drop-off times that for
me
is all the more reason um to not be
expanding vastly in this way traffic
movements
along um primrose lane when many
children
actually need to cross that road in the
morning and at home time on the
return uh on the way to school and on
the return home
so for me this is about uh this is about
road safety and pedestrian safety um
as an access to the site and to be quite
honest with you i know we've done this
already
but it clearly states the transport
statement does not
include a capacity assessment of the
access
and to me the access is what it's all
about and i would very much like to have
seen
um that assessment within the report
thank you thank you councillor foster
thank you chair yeah my concerns are
still around
the adopted local plan t2 uh
specifically
uh part b which states the site is
accessible to a road network of adequate
standard
to accommodate the anticipated traffic
generated by development
safely and without detriment to the
character of the road network so it's
the anticipated traffic generated
uh by the development safely without
detriment so it's the anticipated thing
that bothers me
uh that's my concern t2 b
of the adopted local plan one of the
concern uh
i'd like to mention and perhaps uh this
could be feedback
um to red miles uh
it's the it's the offer of 106 monies uh
we've got uh a figure has been put on it
by
uh our parks which is uh 47 000
uh towards and that's based on 50 houses
so it's the
it's a requirement of 47 000 um
towards a local park if you look what a
local park
costs uh if you look at what from a
district point of view not from a parish
point of view but from a district point
of view
47 000 buys you nothing at all zero
for anything from the district um you're
looking at something like
90 if you look at something like the
proposed one at thermia
you're looking at something like 90 000
to get anything like just for a basic
park
in an area like this so i'd like to see
if they ever come back for
30 houses again if they did i'd like to
see
something like an offer of around about
90 000
uh if it was for um so i'd like that
minuted please
uh that i'd like a higher offer if they
came back for a lower amount of houses
uh something like around 90 100 000 that
would provide
uh something for the area not 47.
thank you chair chair before members um
make their resolution and not the
resolutions make their
motions chairman i just say a couple of
words about what's been said please
yes certainly just on on the various
points that have been raised chair
the issue about the number of housing
houses has been raised
and i know what said in the publication
draft local plan about 30 dwellings
and the application seeks 50 but
irrespective of that chat
members need to assess what harm would
arise
from 50 dwellings as opposed to 30 and
is
that additional 20 dwellings harmful
just in terms of the sustainable issues
that council shipment
mentioned um condition number three of
the
recommendation does allow for some
economic benefits from the scheme by
seeking to secure some local
opportunities within any build
phase of the development but it has
generally been accepted by inspectors
chair that housing
in itself does bring both social and
economic benefits
to an area and members do need to weigh
that in the planning balance
in terms of the highway issues chair i
understand and
see that members are very concerned
about that aspect of the
of the scheme but again it's an issue of
what
evidence is that members have that would
override the evidence that's been put
forward by the applicant and assessed by
the highway authority
in terms of the 106 one is changes to
point the council foster made the
106 monies isn't necessarily to provide
new facilities it but it's to mitigate
the impact of
the development itself and there is a
criteria set out in the
supplementary planning document which
officers and
applicants do work towards and that sets
out a
number of amounts with any new dwelling
houses so
it would be difficult in my opinion to
require a greater sum of money from the
applicant in this or any other
circumstance without
evidence to suggest that's warranted to
mitigate the scale of
the new developments proposed i'm
grateful for that
chair thank you thank you if there's no
other
comment i'm going to open the floor for
a motion to put forward
councillor armitage and then council
shipment
yeah thank you chair uh i
put the motion forward to go against
office as a recommendation for 50 houses
uh i don't see any point mentioning 30
because it's the plan which
is it's the application which is on the
table
i agree with it you know i mean we could
see
uh it goes against the uh
the draft local plan which only said
30 at the time uh
we could mention t2b uh
of the highways but i think if it were
to go to appeal
they would just point to the fact that
the highways issue
had been uh sorted out by the
local highways people and i think the
safest route
uh for officers to defend would be
uh that it went against the local plan
which would only uh propose 30 houses on
this side
i just come back on them other members
may
make comments chad it's clearly and for
the council to defend any decision to
refuse the application chair
and as officers we we seek to do that of
course we do when
has to do so but again and cancer arms
mentioned it goes against the
draft local plan which specifies 30
dwellings but
cataract's chair in my opinion hasn't
set out why
the publication draft local plan and the
designation of 30 dwellings
as opposed to the 50 that is now
proposed would be harmful what is the
planning harm
from that increase from 30 to 50 chen
i think the council would need to
understand that to be able to
defend any reason for refusal on that
grounds just to identify it doesn't
comply with the wording of the plan
chair i don't
believe would be sufficient
well i think it would be powerful when
you consider the
uh road movement if nothing else uh
you know i mean we
had this uh on the previous application
i remember it well
about it and it would be detrimental to
the area
uh whether it's sustainable uh as
as gs1 uh is uh is in doubt
and uh it's in its uh development on a
greenfield site also
would that be suitable for you adrian
ultimately shouts for members to
determine what um they wish to determine
an application
on chair and it's for the planning
committee to make that judgment but
um if members were minded to follow
closer armitage's motion in this
instance chair
the words i have is that it's against
the draft local plan which specifies 30
dwellings
and it would lead to additional road
movements
it would be detrimental to the area and
um not sustainable development and
to help to the greenfield site chair
thank you councillor shipman i saw your
hand was up
yeah were you moving to motion then uh
[Applause]
it's a 70 increase almost adrian in the
amount of houses
this is not we're not just talking you
know 10 we're talking 70 percent
increase on what was
finally agreed five years ago after
multiple attempts are trying higher
numbers
so it's clearly you know it's not just
us who sat on this committee it's
clearly been an issue
that's gone back a while um with other
members on
planning committees and i think that
that is a detrimental impact if you're
going to increase any development size
by 70 you're going to have a
clearly a bigger a significant impact on
the local area and so i think that's
probably the strongest argument but
i do actually think we need to include
this highways one because
we we always fall into the trap of
saying well
county has said x y and z so we can't
possibly improve it
well i i'll give you exhibit a which is
another more road
before lane ends roundabout start
starting my ward in wingworth
where the planning department didn't
include highways
and only because the inspector turned
upon the day in a good mood
decided to include it late as a
submission
so that people could actually debate it
on the day uh
that actually got canned off the back of
an hour's issue that we're never going
to be intended to be in the refusal
so i think that we do need to include
that in clearly there's people with
views
and have been here today and members the
highways is an issue i don't see how you
can properly assess
something from a computer sat behind a
desk
in an office you need to go and count
piles
over a long period of time to see what
the actual impact is not shoving it
through a model
so i do think we need to include t2
um and
yes yes sorry yeah so if we can include
id3
uh in the developing local plan ss1
because i don't think it's sustainable
whatsoever
um and the lc one
and then in the current local plant they
the relevant policies are
obviously ps1 um
or is it t2 and
is the allocations on this one but yeah
the relevant basically relevant policies
in both please adrian
um in our second council armitages
motion if he's happy to accept those
amendments
yeah just um for clarity chair
would members be setting out two reasons
for a refusal chair first of all that
50 dwellings is a greater number than
set out in the local plan which
specifies 30 dwellings
represents unsustainable form of
development in the junta greenville site
adversely impacting the character of the
area chair as one
and secondly that there's an
unacceptable impact on the development
severely impacting on highway safety
and then the relevant policies that
council shipment has mentioned that
would
divide into two or our members i'm
seeking just to have the one reason for
refusal which melds those two together
yeah just seeking clarification adrian
you know you know this
sorry sorry not through the chair but
the highways issue
is because the evidence we're being
provided with is not adequate enough
that we need to see an in-depth
assessment of this area
all we've got at the minute is some
model that's been produced from a desk
that's been admitted by the agent so
we're trying to make a decision based on
someone that's sat behind a desk and
hasn't actually
assessed the junction and the relative
impact on the neighboring highway
i think that needs to be done in order
for us to make a decision one way or the
other
is everyone happy with that um
apologies to elongate the discussion on
this book
um just need to clarify clarity that
other
one reason or two reasons chair and also
just to clarify that council shipmans
mentioned that there's an issue in
sufficient information
to allow a proper assessment of the
application in terms of the highway
safety elements
if members are minded to accept the
recommendation chair my suggestion would
be that
the final wording of the i understand
two reasons for refusal
are finalized by myself in consultation
with yourself and the vice chair
should we take a vote on it uh just
before then can we just be
absolutely clear as to uh what the
motion is effectively it's
to um reject the officer recommendations
um to approve the application so to
reject the application
and the grounds essentially are because
of the
um size of the application 50 dwellings
rather than 30
as set out in the uh draft local plan
and then also concerns about the impact
on how
uh highway safety and i think what seems
to be emerging from this
is members concerned about it because i
think you feel as if there isn't
sufficient evidence or inflation
upon which to actually make a firm
decision so those the two basis
uh for the um ridge well for the um for
the recommendation
and then with any um conditions as
um adrian has said to be actually
determined in consultation with the
chair
councillor foster yeah if you can just
come in at that point
uh i don't step in your tools counselor
shipment um
or castle armitage at all on this but uh
i
know we don't have any we don't have the
the information we need to be able to
give it
uh plenty permission but even with the
information we do have
uh i still think t2b that it's
uh it's got to accommodate the
anticipated traffic generated by the
development safely already
so already what where the information
we've already got is enough to say
that the anticipated traffic uh
uh generated uh won't work won't
uh be a detriment uh to the current
character of the road network so it's
not just that we don't have the
information what the information we do
have
um as well if that makes sense council
shipment yeah
you follow me on that
kinder i mean i think the information is
wrong
because i think saying you've got 30 you
can have 30 movements or whatever it was
with 50 hours when the average falls
paralysis is 1.2 or something
it doesn't even make sense the numbers
don't add up so i think the
the proper assessment's not been done or
someone's just made numbers up behind
the desk
i think the way to to deal with that
would be to
not rely on the insufficient information
if members are of the view that
even if the initial information was
submitted there unlikely to be convinced
about the
acceptability of 50 dwellings
how do we know that until we've seen the
evidence it's like
we can't make a decision based on some
information we don't have already we'll
be pre-determining the decision at that
point
we need
we've got clarity in the the reasons
that members are voting on chair
i'm happy to obviously as officers we're
here to
implement the decision of members that's
that's our role
just trying to be clear in what you
would like as a committee if you might
need to accept the resolution what you
would like in the
refusal and without clarity it does
leave officers sometimes
in some difficulty to be sure that we
are actually
implementing the members decision
so i'm happy to put in insufficient
information if members would like that
leaving in that's absolutely fine
but i'm going to get my membership
i i think we need to leave both of those
two we choose it
because like i said you know we don't
want to leave us
all short if we've got to find ourselves
defending the this development if it
goes to an appeal
i think it's there's solid arguments the
fact that we've got information that
isn't clear doesn't make mathematical
sense to us
um and like i say the allocation as
clear as day
says 30 in the upcoming draft local plan
and this application is for 50.
i think you know residents need to be um
confident that our plan
is a plan for the future and not
something we just change on a win
so i think that these two issues
together give us a solid argument to
reject this
okay thank you are you clear with that
alan yes
i think joe what's essentially come out
of that is that um
committee or the the motion before the
committee is to reject officer um
recommendations on the grounds that this
would be an unsustainable development
given that it would consist of 50
dwellings rather than 30
as set out in the draft local plan and
then the second actually strand for this
is that a committee reject the
application or
propose to reject their application on
the grounds of traffic management and
road safety implications
both in terms of the information which
is before the committee
and concerns about uh information which
is yet to be provided
to the committee is that the essence of
it members
yes it is i'm seeing lots of heads
nodding up and down let's take a vote on
it
nikki are you ready and thank you chair
so we'll do a vote on this by
members could clearly say for against or
abstain for the motion
to reject cancer armitage
counselor barry or castle
cooper abstain
cancer elliot abstain
foster or cancer ligate
or have the pots
oh casa powell
or cancer bridgeway
abstain catheros
or
chair that is nine votes four zero
against with three abstentions that
motion is carried
thank you um i'm going to call for a
comfort break now i see
that there's been some requests for this
so if we can reconvene
at 10 to 3.
thank you all very much
so
thank you and welcome back everybody
hope you're all refreshed we'll move on
to the second application
which is at homewood which is ned
forward slash
two zero forward slash zero zero eight
six one
four with slash fl and
so once again in line with normal
practice i'm going to ask the planning
officers
about any late comments or reports that
have been produced and for the planning
manager to give a brief presentation
showing
any photos and plans of the site the
facilitator will share the presentation
on screen
this means i might find it difficult to
see everybody
therefore i will allow the officers to
complete their presentation
and ask members to reserve any points of
order questions
about the process until the end
thank you and that's because there'll be
plenty of time for any questions etc
and we'll move on to the second planning
application
which is being dealt with by adrian i
believe
that's right chair yes
if you'd like to start your presentation
let's uh i normally do share i'll just
do a brief introduction then go through
the slides with members but in this case
chair i'd like to
refer members in respect of the
application at home woods the late reps
report that was sent out yesterday
afternoon it contains a number of
late reps which hopefully assist members
the application in this instance shares
its consent
in full correct warehouse building
extension to an existing premises
on land off park road at homewood the
application site is currently primarily
covered in trees and grassland chair
with footpaths running along the western
side
boundary and through the site it is
proposed that
the footpath that runs east west is
diverted
not through this application share but
by the process
but it will be a consideration it's
proposed here that in this instance
20 full-time equivalent new jobs will be
created as a result of the extension
which is a 24-hour per day operation
that's proposed at her wood
site is currently unallocated in your
local plan chair but lies within the
settlement of heath homewood
and previously consent has been granted
to use the area
for the construction of a car park or
and or a hgv area
the site is bounded on its southern edge
by residential units referred to in the
report
industrial units to the north and
generally east and west
the building itself chair will be just
over 15 meters in height which is
very approximately twice the size of a
domestic dwelling house
an 88 space car parking area will be
corrected
created to the western boundary with a
three meter high landscape bund
performed to the southern boundary and
generally chair the
environmental health officers are
requiring a two meter high
acoustic fence the top of that and the
condition that's recommended
addresses that issue well it's an
allocated
chair the site lies in the second limits
of homewood so in planning policy terms
there would be no
restriction on the site being developed
per say subject to the other
considerations
an area of informal open space that's
currently treed would be lost to make
way for the building
this of course needs to be weighed
against the other benefits that may
arise
and also the formation of the three
meter high 10 meter wide landscape
that would replace some of those trees
due to its
place within and surrounded by other
development the loss of this area trees
is not considered overriding by officers
in this
case and the new building is considered
on balance to be unacceptable
the area of woodland would be lost and
the wildlife trust of sort recompense in
the form of compensation for this chair
the applicant is often smaller some
money than requested
but considers that in conjunction with
retention improvement on site of areas
of woodland
the ecological concern is overcome
officers consider again on balance
that is the case chain neighboring
properties has always
been affected by the new development
however in view of the distances of the
properties from the new building
and the imposition of conditions that
restrict noise
as recommended by the environmental
health officers is concluded that impact
is acceptable the precise distances
chair has set out in the officer report
ron considered any other technical
issues that were short in the
application necessarily being refused
so in conclusion chair when weighing the
economic benefits the scheme would bring
to the area
the mitigation against the environmental
impact officers consider that unbalanced
development is unacceptable
subject to conditions for the final
woody chair delegated to myself
to conclude that the century 1066
agreement
set out in the office reporting if i
could ask
nikki church just to share the
presentation with you thanks nikki
the first slide chair is showing the
application site and you can
see park road that runs roughly
left to right across the middle top of
the screen industrial areas
both sides of that and the application
site the area
hashed in brown share with the existing
premises the building that is located
within the
angle of the ale at the western side of
the site residential properties
generally
as members can see to the south and
southeast of the site
thanks nikki this is the current
site share outlined in red it's
currently unoccupied by any building and
we'll see in a second there is a
significant amount of
scrub and trees that occupy the site the
existing building
outlined in blue there on the left top
chair
thanks nikki
this is the site post any development
chair and you can see that the
extension stroke warehouse building on
the
area that's currently treated as an area
to the east that would be for hgv
parking and turning and the car parking
area
you can see is the line of spaces on the
left-hand side of the application site
the bund that i've referred to we'll see
a cross section of that in a second
would run along the west south and
southeast edges of the site
and the small and decreasing in size
area to the far east of the site would
be retained
as an ecological area stroke portland
thanks nikki this is just a close-up
plan of what's proposed share the
warehouse building at the bottom of the
slide
in the car parking area for car vehicles
along the
west of the slide chair thank you nikki
this just shows the depiction of the
building
and it's relatively straightforward in
terms of its design
if we just actually should go on to the
next one nikki please
this is the cross section that i've
mentioned that's through the building
and then through the landscape bund
which is
on the left hand side the drawing then
the trees that will be planted as part
of a
landscaping scheme there's some
discussion at site visits yesterday
share about
retention of any trees what i can advise
members is that the
trees that would be subject of the
treatment on the landscaping one would
be you planting
as part of the submitted landscaping
scheme that would be controlled
through the imposition of conditions
chair the building itself has to say
just over
15 meters in height to the apex of the
roof
thanks nikki that just is just a
photograph
sorry slideshare that shows the various
elements coloured so the new buildings
in the blue the new hardstood areas in
the
pink lilac colour and then the area that
would be either retained or
formed of new planting the landscaping
fund
is the green area thanks nikki
and just some photographs chair showing
the site itself this is a photograph
taken from the
park road new junction into the car
parking area that would be created
you can just see the existing footpath
with two people
wandering into the distance along the
west edge of the site
and you can see this gives a flavor of
how the site is currently
occupied by trees and various ages
the existing building is just the
building you just make out from the very
left top of the slide chair
thanks nikki swings around from that
photograph further along
park road and this is the existing
property that's
used by the applicants and which would
be extended to the rear but this would
be retained this
this part of the building thanks nikki
and again further along the road which
gives a flavor of how
part road is otherwise developed with
other industrial uses
along it both north and south of the
road
thanks nikki
this is taken from the head of one of
the roads on the
south of the site looking into the site
properties beyond the security fence
there
gives again a flavor that the site is
treed
there is vegetation that is currently
occupying it
thanks nikki
this is taken from those dwellings
dwellings on the left-hand side is clear
to
members the site now on the right-hand
side this is one of the walkways that
runs along the site boundary but again
gives a flavor that the site is
currently
treed with shrub shrubbery under story
etc
thanks nikki again we got just got a few
slides here showing the general state of
the site
it is subject to a variety of
um potentially anti-social uses chair
but this just can't again gives a flavor
the site has been allowed to
um develop regenerate whichever word you
wish to use but with
understory trees and shrubs thanks nikki
again chair this is similarly taken off
the site and how it's been
regenerating thanks nikki and again
the next one nikki please
oh that's that's all the slideshare
thank you
thank you adrian and we'll move on to
the speakers
and i have been asked to change this
order in which i've got them here
so i am going to allow that and the
first speaker which is an objector
is mark rongaya
hello yeah i'm minutes when you're ready
okay
hello i'm mark resident of homewood i'm
one of many residents who object to the
development going ahead as planned
and primarily i note that the parish
council objected to the planning
application
on the 23rd of november 2020 citing
concerns on the impact
on local residents 20 written objections
have been made by residents
with more y'all not yet recorded um i
think they arrived last week
and yet no public consultation has been
made
the proposal is highly controversial and
undesirable to residents in its current
state
where a more modest expansion could have
garnered the support of residents
and benefit to the community as well as
the business owners
the council needs all the information to
make an informed decision
however correspondence was still being
received by statutory bodies last week
and the report itself contains factual
inaccuracies
i specifically refer to the neighboring
housing estate no longer being under
construction
secondly the plans would involve the
removal of mature
woodland which is home to wildlife
wildlife spotted by residents includes
birds
foxes bats and butterflies it is also
stated in correspondence from the
derbyshire wildlife trust
on the 19th of january 2021 that the
proposals do not meet
national and local policies regarding
conservation and biodiversity
the planning report suggests 30 000
pounds of section 106 to be granted
for it to counteract the loss of
wildlife whereas the derbyshire wildlife
trust recommended roughly three times
that figure
if the plans were downscaled to retain
some woodland area
biodiversity would be protected and the
net loss of trees would be reduced
the area that creates the border between
the homes and the industrial unit
have been rated as b quality trees
thirdly the size of the plan
construction is alarming
and will impact visual immunity
significantly
a previous application which was
approved on the 26th of jan 2016
was much smaller and did not move the
western public right of way
in the proposed elevations dated on the
10th of march 2021
the building towers over the tree line
this will be a drastic change as the
existing cold store
is hidden entirely from view by the tree
line as evidenced by photographs
the plans also fail to account for the
elevation of the area
the site sits at the bottom of a hill
with residential homes on top of the
hill overlooking the area
causing the visual impact to be ever
more reaching so please
reject this planning application in its
current state ask the developer to go
back to the drawing board to downscale
the plans
address outstanding issues and make this
development work for everybody
thank you do we have any questions
nope thank you we'll move on to the next
speaker which is laura thai
hey oh sorry one moment i did have
someone waving at me
councillor cooper no
okay um laura three minutes off you go
yep the factory's on park road homeworld
just to stay allowed i could sometimes
hear the radio playing and i can tell
you what station they're on
and what song is playing from my front
door to the boundary fence is 25 feet
i can see trees bushes and nests but i
can also see the grey outline
of rick besswick coast storm i've been
in this house
13 years i am a great north tenant and i
and the noise pollution noise has been
consistently getting louder
at autumn and winter due to no leaves on
the trees
the noise from the injustice day is 24
hours seven days a week
there is no break from that humming
sound over the past couple of days i
took decibel readings in the morning
afternoon and night from six feet away
from my front door
and every reading i took was above 42
decibels and sometimes it would reach
the maximum
of 16.1 decibels this to me is sound
pollution as well as the world health
organization pollution
as it should not exceed 50 decibels
and if you bring a cold store even
closer it would be even louder than it
is now
can you turn off your freezer off at
home well these cold stores cannot be
turned off
as there always have goods in them they
have to keep the freezers at a constant
temperature of minus
25 degrees c this has to stop the goods
from being spoiled or worse
wasted this house that i've been in for
13 years when i had
brittled come to my house they said i
had subsidence
and that needs to be underpinned on the
back garden three meters across by three
meters down
i still have constant cracks that every
time i feel or plaster
they always come back i can nearly put
my finger through the gaps in the bottom
of my door
most of my walls has cracks that i have
plastered or filled but still
some cracks come back i also have three
cracks that are getting bigger
getting longer at the front of my house
which are concerning me
both my doors don't look like they fit
in the frames anymore
there has to be something wrong to keep
getting cracks constantly
and you think building a coastal won't
cause
any more damage to my house without
the drilling of metal frames being
pushed into the ground
the highway report always also raises
concerns about vehicles being able to
pass through
and fly tip the proposed three meter
wide half
flight of seconds remain fly tipping and
vehicle traffic in the area
is already a major issue so to allow
a development that potentially gives
easier access strikes me it's
inconsiderate
thank you does anyone have any questions
thank you laura the next speaker i have
is
nicholas smith
claire we don't have a nicholas smith in
the meeting room
okay thank you and the last
objective that i have then is the ward
member councillor susie cornwell
yes before i had my three minutes start
though um
i had a i subjected uh sorry i i put in
another objection
and some concerns about due diligence
due to technical issues they only got
put up on the planning portal
at 10 a am today and i was hoping that
adrian actually might be showing those
photos but he hasn't shown them
so i before you make a decision uh
committee i would really kindly ask that
you look at those as i believe they were
subject they were in your packs
um is that okay that's fine thank you
there's also been an update so if
anybody wants to know about an update
i can offer an update to later date so
okay this application has been rushed
through
only being paused by having to come to
the committee by myself and counselor
lee stone
the emerging plan makes reference to
maintaining the quality of life of our
communities and minimizing noise
disturbance and pollution this
development potentially has all these
effects
we wish to reject offers of
recommendations and believe that this
proposal
would have a significant impact on the
area
there are 23 objection letters from the
community and you have heard them speak
and that's without adequate consultation
as the district councillor i don't want
to speak against the opportunities for
economic growth but i find myself on a
collision course and i have to give
voice to the community
and i'm asking should this development
go ahead certain conditions are applied
which i will raise at the end now we
accept that we live on the doorstep of
an industrialist right and we are proud
that we are part of this
country's economic growth and i am
delighted that this business is doing
well
however none of these 20 jobs will be
filled by local residents
they are all shipped in from darby
magnavail
have shown no respect for the community
god knows when they last litter picked
their land this development was
originally a small car park and
caught officers unawares and suddenly it
became a 16.4 metre high development
that is hundred and 860 square meters
and thirty meters away from residents
property
the original plans show no consideration
for the local community
and officers got them altered but what
we have before us today
is an invasion disruptive unsafe and
pollutant
for a development of this size to be 30
meters from
hundreds of residential properties it
will clearly affect their visual
immunity
the constant low level white noise from
such installations
could be damaging to the mental health
and well-being of neighbouring residents
the building is 16.4 metres high
where do you think the security lights
will be what protection have the
residents got from light
pollution and how much natural light
will be lost and hazardous materials
from the gases from the plant room
and clearly increased heavy goods
movement noise and pollution
all of which will have a serious adverse
effect on hundreds of residents living
so closely to that area i have to
question why
anyone thought that this was acceptable
perhaps they didn't which is why the
public consultation has been so poor
30 seconds remain have serious concerns
about cases of subsidence in the area
i am dealing with four cases on duke's
close
having discussed this with ritnald i
have not seen evidence of a thorough
report to give me sufficient information
that there is definitely no subsidence
in the area
so the conditions i would like to ask
you to impose
the business operation hours are
restricted to account for proximity to
the local residential area
just right here that's time in temple
normanton
i have a few people now carry on
yes please fabulous if that were the
case it could not operate
24 7 then this would be a would this be
a viable proposition for the business
so it could look at becoming a smaller
development
the serious consideration that you give
serious consideration to reducing the
noise
and the safeguarding of residents during
construction and after
a thorough review by the coal board and
by yourself and by brittnell
is taken of the local subsidies issues
that once this smaller development has
happened the owners of the
land maintain it and ensure that it is
free from litter because they
clearly do not do that at the moment
so thank you very much committee for
your consideration
thank you councillor do i have any
questions
councillor ridgeway
yeah um mike um you talk about um
the distance between um the houses and
the development
um would is that one of the areas where
they would lose all the trees
yes and do you know how many new trees
would be planted
what type and how big would they be
may i call on um my colleague mark
vonger who may know the answer to that
exact question because he's been dealing
with the environmental element
i'm sorry chair um he's uh made his
address to the committee
and uh has answered questions from this
point
no further proceedings what's that
he can't take any further part in the
proceedings today i'm afraid
okay councilman it could be a question
that you put to
um the planning officer they should have
okay thank you
are there any counsellor barry
all right in the lamb late
representations you refer to the fly
tipping
and that at one point that's always been
kept clear of fly tipping because the
previous owner did that
do you know why this current owner has
decided not to
maintain the upkeep of that area
i'm afraid i don't know my my husband
actually used to work for rick besswix
when it was rick besswix
and his jobs was to maintain that area
and i can assure you my
husband maintained that area absolutely
brilliantly
and now when mate meg de vale
may develop sorry forgot their name took
over
they have not done that and if you look
at those photographs that fly tipping is
horrendous
it's only going to get worse when the
highway
is more when that with this new proposal
of a footpath
of three meters vehicles can get through
the fly tipping will continue
councillor cornwall as the um your
pictures show all this awful
um subsidence cracking etcetera has this
been ongoing
since the properties were first built
um i i don't know when the properties
were built
this was brought to my attention in
november 2020
may i speak about an update since this
is that allowed
so so the ones that the main ones that
you're looking at are 12.
let me check with the club um share the
purpose of the questions is really for
members to ask for clarification about
any points which have actually been made
in the three-minute presentation rather
than to actually open up any new
um areas of um sort of discussion so i
think it's really a case of is the
update
related to um the specific points that
you've made
in your representation
i i believe they my point will be made
that actually the photographs show that
they are
that written or they're worried
may i speak yes please do
um so since i made um officers aware
that i will be bringing this issue of
subsidence to this meeting
suddenly there's been a flurry of
activity around duke's clothes
where previously there was absolutely
none and laura can attend to that
now the photographs that i've i've put
put on that pack
one of them is 12 duke's clothes i've
been dealing with that case since the
12th of november 2020
rick neld haven't done anything with
that but all of a sudden there's been
this flurry of
activities and they have gone round
this morning they went round to laura's
this morning they went round to 12 dukes
close and they went round to nine dukes
close and they have now told 12
dukes close which is one of the main
photographs that you're looking at
that that that it's so bad that they're
recommending that she actually
vacates that property because they can't
solve the problem in the house
that the damage is so bad which makes me
think that there is a serious issue of
subsidence in the area
and and and the cold authority report
that you've been submitted only talks
about your local development
only talks about the side it doesn't
talk about the houses
near it i think there's going to be an
increase of subsidence
along duke's close and wood street
because of this development okay thank
you
are there any other questions
no thank you thank you counselor thank
you
all right we'll move on then um i'll ask
the planning offices is there any
questions towards the planning officers
no sorry chair we do have um one more
speaker uh andrew lawrence
oh i beg your pardon that's the
applicant isn't it
yes sure apologies
mr lawrence are you there yes i am here
yes
thank you good afternoon everyone i'm
the director of magna belt
magmel is a local employer and has
operated in the borough for over 30
years with the facility and park road
opening in 1998.
due to a general lack of suitable modern
cold start facilities in the uk
the company plays a significant role in
the industry and wish to further expand
to meet ever-increasing demands for the
storage of food and perishable goods
recent coverage related impacts and
pending uncertainty around the longer
term implications of brexit
have resulted in customers expressing
the need for greater storage capacity
this development will ensure that future
demand for food can be met
one of the council's strategic aims is
to unlock economic growth potential of
the area
supporting enterprise major employment
growth
and providing employment locally to
enable people to work close to where
they live
we currently employ around 150 people
with the majority living locally
the extension of our cultural facility
will enable us to meet increased
customer data in demand
and in turn create a further 20 20
full-time positions
which will advertise locally that we do
currently for any new roles
we as a business will recruit locally as
and where possible
this development represents a 10 million
pound investment in the park road
site our existing refrigeration plant
needs to be replaced
and so we're using this opportunity to
replace it with a new platform serving
our existing culture facility
along with the extension new
technological advances and refrigeration
will mean that the new refrigeration
equipment that we are
using and replacing um will be quieter
than the currently installed equipment
so we'll receive see a reduction in
noise from the current refrigeration
and through and also the new
refrigeration must be cleaner and more
efficient contributing to the carbon net
gold that magneville have the new
extension sits much lower than our
residential neighbours to the south
our neighbours are more than 30 meters
away and we're proposing a three meter
landscape fund
the two meter high acoustic fence along
the top
this is to also reduce any visual and
noise impact to residents
and noise impact assessment has been
prepared to support the application and
the council's environmental health
officer has no technical objection to
the proposal subject
to a number of conditions which will
comply with before being
before the building is operational this
is all to ensure that residents are
protected from any noise
it is well known the application site is
currently used for flight tipping
public rights away across the site do
not feel particularly safe
the proposal provides an opportunity to
tidy the site up
and divert the path around the perimeter
of the site to create a safe and
accessible accessible route for
pedestrians 30 seconds remain
a new access will serve to separate our
hdg 8gb
movements and start vehicles which
improve pedestrian safety for staff
and visitors there are no technical
objections to the application and we've
offered a summer 30
000 to enhance biodiversity locally i
trust that you
will be able to support your office's
recommendation and support the proposal
thank you thank you i have a question
for you mr lawrence and it has been
raised earlier
um you speak about planting between
the new fencing etc is this mature
planting
or is it just small planting
i i don't know um unfortunately
i will be able to believe i can find out
whilst uh
whilst i'm here if i can answer that
shortly yes that'd be very good thank
you
councillor potts councillor armitage
thank you chair
uh mr lawrence just a couple of quick
questions first ones for clarity
um about ownership of the site section
4.14 states that the site belongs to dcc
whereas section 7.8 states formerly
owned by dcc so if you could just
clarify
uh which of those statements is is
correct at this moment in time
and my second question is about the 88
space
car parking um the report says that the
proposal will is anticipated to generate
approximately
20 new jobs um can you explain
why you need 88 extra spaces
um for 20 new jobs
thank you um
in regards to the ownership i believe
it's formerly ownership by the dcc
in regards to the spaces is we remove um
car parking that is currently
at the front of the site
um to the side area
so we would be using current so it would
increase it by 20 but we also have
parking on site for 66 spaces so it's
not 88 additional it
does include okay thank you
and in regards to the planting um
new planting would be as approved by the
planting scheme uh with local authority
retaining existing
where we can thank you councillor
armitage
thank you chair uh you mentioned that
you're putting a new uh
fridge plant in uh can you tell me
roughly
how many decibels uh this plant
is because there's been a question about
noise
the other thing is uh the
lorries uh are they refueled
uh on the road or do you have diesel
storage
on site and uh
let me see there was uh the question of
the i think it's it's a gas uh
refrigerant that you're using are you
using one of the
uh green type which is not
toxic um in regards to your first
question
i don't know the decimals myself
but it will be quiet in the current
existing plant and it is in a very
similar location to the current plant
um so as part of the development we
replace in the current plant room with a
fully
new one and although it will be powering
more cold storage spaces
it will be quieter than the current what
we will be currently having in place
um in the refrigeration gases uh it will
be an ammonia system
um with a very very small amount of
ammonia
which is a normal top which is not
normal greenhouse gas
which is the current um what people want
for the refrigeration
right uh and if i may just uh another
point there's been question about
uh subsidence in that area
i take it that uh this building will be
on a
a raft of substantial thickness to
alleviate any problems caused by
subsidence here
and as a result would i be correct in
saying that
this building uh will not uh cause
subsidence
as a result of its uh design
yes that's it we shouldn't call
substance it won't cause substance
right thank you
what about the diesel by the way oh
sorry no we don't have
any um diesel um
on the store where we're talking about
there won't be any refueling
right and on the noise assessment in
regards to the decibels of the
department that's in the planning
application
rather comply with all proposed
conditions
okay thank you very much thank you
that's the foster
uh thank you chair i'm mark foster a
member of call austin
um afternoon myself lauren's
um it's been mentioned a few times now
about uh the people that are employed it
says
the 98 full-time staff 80 agency workers
and you mentioned 150 people employed
yourself and the number for
full-time positions is an extra concept
uh something i'm particularly interested
in myself
is the economic development side of it
um
we've heard that a lot of workers come
in from derby
and you mentioned a lot of uh your
present workers
uh come from uh the local
uh the local area could you give me an
idea percentage-wise on how many of the
150
come from the local area please i i
don't um but from from my previous
experience of working
within the warehouse um i would say
close to 72 80 of our
contracted workforce live in the local
area we've also increased our employment
away from
um agency employment and actually
increased the permanent uh quite
drastically in the last three months as
well
yeah i'm following on from that thank
you for that following on from that the
extra 20 will they be agency staff or
would be advertising them as full-time
there will be full-time positions we're
trying to move away from having an
agency staffing site and move to
full-time positions
as part of the the growth that we've
seen in the industry it's enabled us to
have more kind of solid ad
full-time contracts rather than any kind
of seasonal work which has meant that
we've been able to
increase full-time employment excellent
thank you
mr lawrence i have one question it was
raised by my um
colleague councillor potts but i didn't
quite hear the answer
the regarding of ownership is that dcc
still in ownership of the land
i don't believe it is pcc anymore it's
owned by your company
yes the company you're representing
right thank you very much
i believe we bought it from the dcc um
as
um land to construct on
the development thank you are there any
other questions
counselor shipment i
andrew you're right um the the concern
seems to
me to be how large this thing is and how
close it is to the houses
i was just wondering does it have to be
this big
what what's the thinking behind it being
this big um because clearly i think
it probably is some middle ground here
that could perhaps be met
but looking at it i mean what was
talking to was it 30 meters
tall i mean that's that's significant
um and you know twice as big as a house
i don't think he could build a man big
enough and put a fence on top
to disguise that from 30 40
meters away um so i just wondered
is does it have to be this big and why
what's your thinking as a business
behind
so it's it's 16 meters high um the gap
is 30 meters
16 rather than 30. and the the
the reason for it being this size is um
obviously we have to fill the room with
cold the cold store runs at -18
and actually the more product we can put
in there the more efficient it is the
more green it is
um alongside we've actually been able to
turn the plant off for longer because
when the park when the plant when the
room is actually at minus 18
the actual um refrigeration turns itself
off so the idea is
we have the refrigeration turned off as
much as possible for electricity usages
and
for noise um and it all comes down to
the building cost versus the the cost
that we can actually generate
um from actually the building and kind
of building higher
enables us to um enables us to maximize
the
storage density in that area and that is
the ability that makes it pay
if if we couldn't go that size i don't
think the project would actually be
viable
and the employment um wouldn't
be um wouldn't it be viable but also
although it's a 16 meter tall building
we're actually having to
dig down into the ground and because of
the levels so it will only appear as a i
think it's so i think there's a three
meter
being built along the side so i know
it's still large but i think it works
out
with the fencing as well about a
12 meter 11 meter high building
are there any further questions
counselor ridgeway
yeah going back to what councillor
shipman was saying about the size of the
development looking at the plan from
what
um adrian showed us it looks as if
you're wiping out the whole of the green
area and replacing it with just a few
trees and i'm appalled at that
you talk about you know 30 000 for
biodiversity
that's not going to pay you know that's
just peanuts
that's a drop in the ocean i think
really you know i agree with with castle
shipment it needs to be made smaller and
the green areas are gone and you're
getting rid of
ancient you know old mature trees and
and hedges and everything through the
chair this is supposed to be questions
to mr lawrence it's not supposed to be
statements and speeches
thank you
so have we actually any more questions
nope oh counselor armitage
yeah if i could come back to the
gentleman
uh the lorries when they're waiting to
be
filled uh filled uh will their fridge
plants be running
uh yes we can get them to return their
fish parts off so no they might be
running we can request
that they're turned off right because
that's been one of the
concerns because some of these uh petty
diesels on the front make it
quite a noise especially when they're
going to be changed
yeah we're able to get them to be turned
off the refrigeration when they're on
site right so they're turned off
and they want me to make a lot of noise
on site no
and in regards to the mound i've just
had
it's five meters below the mountain
actually dug down five meters so the
building would only appear to be 11
meters high
and i believe the the diesel
refrigeration is good
so them uh they'll be electric will they
they're all inside the building so there
aren't any external forklifts
um they're all all of the um lorries
reverse directly to the building
and the forklift trucks are internal and
electric
right thank you
councillor barry can i just say one
thing in regards to the trees
um we've actually had a tree survey
carried out
and most of the trees are actually um
not mature and they've been self-seeded
and are poor quality trees so as part of
the area that we're looking to develop
they're not mature trees that are in
place thank you
council barry yeah earlier on you were
asked about sustenance and could you
guarantee that there wouldn't be any and
and you said you could guarantee
i'm a bit concerned because when you've
just said a few minutes ago that you're
going to be drilling quite far down into
the ground
um in order for this building to not be
as high as it is
do you not think that if you're sat
anywhere near a coal mine or a
you know a shaft or something that's
down there that could cause a substance
do you not think that the drilling
deep would be an issue sorry i didn't
say jordan
we would dig dig to the side so there
was a mound
where earth has already been banked up
and we would just further bank the earth
and dig into that
so it wouldn't be drilling into it it's
leveling out the site as part of the
development
what about the foundations of the
building
they'd be standard foundations we've
there is already a cold store built
there that
we wouldn't call subsystems with
building development
are there any further questions
no thank you mr lawrence
i'm now going to ask if there's any
questions for the officers planning
officers
okay counselor armitage
uh it's a question to uh adrian
uh and we're talking about the trees
uh i mean if we were to go with this
plant
would there be uh could we put a
condition on that they were mature
trees and also uh if you put them
in uh if you put shrubs
down below as well to mitigate noise
could that be a condition because it's
all right i'm in a tall
spindly tree but the noise will just go
through but if you put some
uh shrubs and things which are already
there
uh surely that would help to filter the
noise as well
chair the detailed landscaping scheme
planting scheme that accompanies the
application does show
a variety of tree heights being planted
the the highest there are a number of
trees that are three meters high but
generally speaking the area of
the wooded areas that are proposed
around about two meters high
just to be clear as well chair that the
um bonding area to the south south east
and southwest is
three meters high and it's conditioned
that there would be a two meter high
acoustic fence on top of there but in
addition to that
as cache armitage has asked there is
understory
planting also proposed in the wooded
area that would occupy
the space beneath the tree canopy at
a lower level that would be planted on
the bond
so wouldn't in itself i don't think
filter any noise but in association with
the bund and the other planting and the
acoustic fencing
it is considered by environmental health
colleagues that that would present
an acceptable environment should consent
be granted along of course with all the
other conditions that there's been
discussion about noise for example there
are
three or four conditions that address
noise there's a condition that would
require
the lorries to be switched off when not
moving
so they're all contained in the the
annex lake comments report chair
and the uh acoustic fence i presume that
at the moment there isn't one there at
all
not the time to wear chair no right
thank you
councillor barry yeah adrian it was
referred to earlier on
that um there hadn't been full
consultation
can you tell me whether that's true or
not and has there been full consultation
and in relation to we were also informed
that there was some information that
we've not actually received as a
planning committee
can you confirm yes or no please
the consultation chair i believe that
68 neighboring properties or people have
either been consulted or written to and
of course the application has been
otherwise advertised as required
by ourselves as local planning authority
so from a purely a planning point of
view
i'm happy that the application has been
adequately consulted on
and you've received a number of
representations on the application which
would
back up that contention chair whether
there
is an understanding that there should
have been wider consultation from the
company with
the local community ahead of the
application being submitted or
subsequent to that
i don't know but as far as the planning
requirements
are concerned and as local planning
authority we have certain
responsibilities
as far as i'm aware we have addressed
those and undertaken those
responsibilities and discharged them in
full chair just in terms of information
i'm i'm not actually aware of any
information that
we have that we wouldn't disclose to
members we wouldn't do that in any case
and in all eventualities the information
we have is publicly available in any
case so
as far as i'm aware against there's
nothing that we have
or we would ever keep from the planning
committee knowingly
that would mean that you haven't got
information to make your decision i'd be
very disappointed if we did that we
would only do that
by error chair and if we did you'd
obviously have my apologies for doing we
would never keep any information
knowingly from members in
making the decision that you have before
you
i think adrian what i was trying to
relate to is that there was some new
information that had come to light i'm
not saying you're
withholding anything from us
purposefully um
but it it sounded as if there's some new
stuff that might have come to light that
you know you've not had a chance to get
out um before this meeting today that's
all
i'm not aware of anything shared i don't
know if council barry has anything
in particular in mind
no i'm just going off what was said
earlier on in the in the meeting i'm not
aware that there's any information that
isn't before members
this afternoon chair thank you
thank you are there any further
questions
no thank you adrian
okay um just to remind you that i'm
going to open the floor for
debate and i would ask that you don't
make any motions whilst this
is in process thank you
anyone would like to open the floor for
debate
councillor barry yeah i've got
a few concerns around this application
um and my biggest ones around subsidence
that building is very going to be very
very close to those houses and whichever
amount of
maneuvering you take and if you're
anywhere near a mine shaft it could
cause
further um subsistence to the properties
in the area
um i'm also concerned about the size of
this
building is rather a large building and
as several people have said before
um they think it'd be better if it was a
smaller building
and i i feel disappointed that the
company haven't done
wider consultation with the neighboring
properties and the people that are going
to be
severely affected by it so for me
um i don't know if i'm right then i
can't ask
um council cornwall anymore about about
it but
it made it sound to me that there's some
information that we hadn't got
that was coming to light and i think i
personally would prefer this to be
deferred so that we can look at it
further and find out what that is and
hopefully
know more about the subsidence of the
properties as to whether that substance
has been caused
and could be made worse by the the
development of this building
council armitage
i i think actually looking at uh the
question of subsidence is that
all these buildings uh they're built
on a reinforced raft and so they
actually
float and they won't cause any problems
with subsidence
the subsidence is already there there's
subsidence uh i mean we've
said uh about the problems with the
houses
but those the uh mine shafts were
underneath those houses
long before this building was put up and
there's also another
gold store across the road there which
is
uh i understood as one of the biggest in
europe
so i don't think this one's going to
make that much difference
uh i think the actual woodland
uh well quite frankly it looks a mess
it's been used for dumping stuff and
it's got to be apparently used for drug
users
well i wouldn't want to walk through
there with a chance of
stabbing myself with a hypodermic needle
has been
dumped and i think it's a question that
we're going to
clear this air is going to be cleared uh
and made
more amenable uh the footpaths will be
reinstated and there'll be a fence round
so the fly tipping can't take place
uh and i think with the
number of people this company is going
to take
on outweighs anything else
uh i don't like seeing trees chopped
down but the quality of the dresses are
there
they look to be all self-set and the
site's just being let go
and it'll be cleaned up and it'll be
made more
amenable i'm quite sure and plus the
fact that these
extra jobs in an area will you know
they're not that many jobs going
and we need to attract companies to the
area
so that's my thoughts
thank you any other thoughts comments
counselor shipment yeah
for me i'm actually a bit disappointed
with this one actually so i would have
liked to have seen some of it some
innovation on action in the building
itself because
given the work in our whole ward it
could have been all sorts of
environmental um things that they've
done
it could have literally married the
actual cold story itself
gave it a grass roof anything try and
help mitigate how it looks to the
surrounding neighbors
but we seem to just landed with putting
a a soil mound and then a fence on top
of it
which is to me is kind of you know it's
missed an opportunity
to really have put like that area on the
map as
the economic growth in in you know in
the green space
um but like i say we just seem to
to just have a massive building with a
fence on top of a map
to try and hide it which is not even
going to do that
um so i
yeah i'm just a bit disappointed with
the plan itself actually i thought you
know
i i would have loved to have seen some
innovation here
um but we don't seem to have that um but
the big things for me are the visuals
noise pollution and
you know what is it going to look like
from someone's house
um these are considerations which i'm
leaning toward to reject at the moment
thank you any other comments
no counselor foster yeah
i sympathize with a lot of the comments
i've heard about this
but uh i've yet to hear anything that
goes against uh you know
our planning rigs why we can knock this
bike
i don't i don't see anything i'm saying
anybody quote anything yet i've heard
the concern about employment
noise all the things i've got a lot of
sympathy for
a lot um i've made the same arguments
myself whenever
i post things here uh before i was on
planning and
in planning but here i find it difficult
those will be my comments you know i've
not heard anything yet
thank you chair thank you
any other comments
no we'll move on to the next section
then where we would
i would ask for a motion so i'm just
going to ask alan to recap
okay chair um just to remind members
uh to bear in mind that promotion
must be moved and seconded before a vote
is taken
if an amendment to emotion is moved and
seconded
then that emotion that amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
uh the reasons for moving now motion
against offer recommended
officer recommendations i should
comprise
the relevant planning issues and be
supported by the evidence
as necessary if a motion to reject
officer recommendations fails or in
other words is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion
in favor of the recommendations or
another course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
thank you chair thank you
do i have a motion on the table
councillor armitage and councillor barry
uh i'm though that we go with
officer's recommendation uh but
we also we take into consideration
all the conditions of not having uh
the fridge units running on the lorries
uh the environmental
uh aspect of this that
it is uh you we use uh
the the uh
mature trees and there's also sufficient
uh in the base as well to do away with
the noise
as regards the noise the operator
has said that it's a new
fridge unit that's going in and it will
be quieter than the existing one
and this coupled with the acoustic uh
fence that's going to be there should
alleviate a lot of the problem
if you all remember that the first
fridge you used to have
made a hell of a lot of noise and the
one you've got now
doesn't you doesn't make half as much
noise and doesn't
and doesn't use as much electricity
electricity
so that's why i moved to go with
officers recommendation
with a number of uh
okay conditions got council harrion
council of boston we
speak yes chair thank you
um i would have proposed to defer this
application
i think we need more information in
relation to
the noise side of it um consultation
definitely needs to take place with the
residents that are living there that
will be the people that will have to put
up with that noise
and all the other stuff the um
environment albeit the trees may not be
big massive mature trees they're still
there i accept the fire tipping
shouldn't be there but that's down to
the company they should have shifted
that already
but my biggest concern is around um the
noise and pollution level
the size of the building and the
subsistence i'd like to see
some more i know these go on floating
things but there's still a matter of
ground work that needs to be done
and i appreciate
refer this until we've got further
information
thank you councillor foster thank you
chair
i'd like to second council armitage's uh
proposal to go with that officer's
recommendations
um i've got a lot of sympathy from all
i've heard today
uh but i don't i've never heard anything
anybody yet put anything forward
apart from the deferment that uh can
support uh
rejecting this there's nothing there uh
what we can do
is put forward that it's uh noisy we're
not sure about this we haven't seen the
information yet
this will get passed on a bill now while
that's not a reason in itself
you know there's nothing here for me i
can't see anything
and that's our job here to look at them
this proposal and go to the vote please
could i just come back to your chair
and that's the number of jobs you know a
lot of people are going to be out of
work after this pandemic
and let's say if we can keep 20 off the
dole queue
it'll be a move in the right direction
and we're looking at
basically uh 20 jobs or
20 trees and you know
uh we've got to look at the job
situation and making these companies
successful
so that they work and are attracted to
this
area and after all it is an industrial
site that there are on
chair can i just come in very briefly i
i don't know if i caught all the council
armitage is said in terms of conditions
i heard that he would like adding to the
condition about
the vehicle engines being switched off
the fridge
units i believe should also not run
while stationary
and i just wonder whether i missed
anything else that he said chair
yeah it was to do with the trees uh
let's have some mysteries
big ones uh and also uh
shrubs in the bottom to help filter the
noise out
and have it all done before they start
any work
it's um in terms of the vote chair
remembers
seeking a revised condition that will
require taller trees than the
three meters but more predominantly two
meter high trees
so you want to draw the trees in that
five meters high for example
some some five meter high trees for
example yeah
nodding heads over that yes
it would be a revised landscape scheme
you would require a chair and then it's
implementation
yeah yeah anything to cut the noise down
okay alan i'm coming back to you now
we've got two motions on oh sorry well
we've only got the one motion chair
as things stand um and there hasn't been
anyone uh no one's moved a amendment to
that motion so that is the motion
uh as things stand at the moment that
you would be voting on
but can i just be clear on that then so
essentially it's to approve
the application in line with opposite
recommendations
with appropriate revised uh conditions
essentially um around the operation of
the facility in terms of the uh
noise reduction and then landscaping
as well as specified at the meeting with
the final conditions to be agreed
in consultation with yourself uh by the
development manager is that
eight members shipment i saw your hand
up
yes thanks [ __ ] i was going to say just
on the plankton the landscaping plan
would it not be worthwhile just planting
the whole banking up with various trees
so it actually creates so it looks like
it's a larger wood than it really is
the whole bank is bounced up so to
residents along that banking
you can have you know two three meter
trees
or whatever it can take that can grow
into it so it looks like it's a
better quality award but really on the
other side clearly it's going to be a
car park however
i believe that is what is this sorry
i think if we so the condition is all to
not
necessarily require the planting scheme
of submissive but to have a revised
scheme i think we
would need that to accommodate the
height of trees that cancer armitage is
talking about and we can perhaps seek to
secure
a denser planting as well as cancer
cancer shipments
referred to chair yeah fill it with
with trees trees and shrubs so it looks
uh so they can't even hardly see the
building
thank you okay um i think we've got
motion
we've got a second so the motion was put
forward by council armitage seconded by
councillor foster and nikki we're going
to go to the vote
chair and as per the last applications
members could clearly say fought against
or
abstain counsel armitage
four
against
chair with nine votes for three against
and zero abstentions that motion is
carried
thank you thank you everybody
[Music]
moving on to the third item on the
agenda
which is a tpo order for wingerworth
trees at hardwick wood
i'm going to ask the officers to give a
presentation
adrian your moocs
apologies chair um just before we go on
to item seven and eight just
to advise members that in terms of these
two items
and provisional orders tpos
representation orders been made on
two areas of woodland that before
members this afternoon
they are made provisionally initially
for six months and it's then
for the authority to either confirm the
order
either confirm it in a modified form or
alternatively not to confirm the order
at all that's the
action that members are required to
perform this afternoon as
officers we don't have powers delegated
to us to confirm or otherwise orders
where we've received representations
in both these cases we have received
representations in respect to the tpo
so it's quite a straightforward matter
for members to consider
confirmation of the order unmodified
confirmation of the order
in a modified form or non-confirmation
in which case the
the order would fall out of the six
months just moving on to the specifics
of item seven share
um refer members to the late updates
reports of yesterday
and in this instance chair the tpo
covers a woodland that sits within the
generally tree landscape of hardwick
wood and adjoins other areas of
protected trees which we'll have a look
at in a second
the order has been made provisionally on
this narrow strip of trees due to
concerns about its potential retention
and loss the site in office's opinion
does offer
amenity value as part of the generally
tree landscape of hardwood wood
but the owner's requirement to gain
access to other woodland holdings they
have close by
could be accommodated by way of
application securing
to a formal process to remove some of
the trees
as such it's recommended by officers
that the tpo was confirmed in its
unmodified form
and if i can just ask nikki if she can
move to the slides please
thank you nikki
the tpm of this instance chair as i say
is a
long thin basically rectangular shape
and the area that's in discussion this
afternoon is that outlined
there at the center of the slide and
it's referred to as w1i woodland one
thanks nikki
you can see that area of woodland the
center of this slide
and these slides are in your your report
i appreciate chair but
this slide seeks to show how that era of
trees is associated with other areas of
protected trees and around this area
particularly the area to the east and
south
the long thin strip that our area is
already protected as woodland
and an area of trees that it would be
associated with
and we have some photos now nikki please
this is well the number of photos which
show the
area of trees that are of interest to
members this afternoon
and the thin strip extends from the
hedgerow that you can just make out on
the left hand side of this slide
and the fence come hedge row on the
right hand side and it's the area
directly in front of where this
photograph's taken
which is taking one from one of the
access roads
within it which gives access to the
properties there and you can see that
the
the trees are generally of a
at least semi-mature if not mature form
thanks nikki
this is a similar photo share again you
can see the long thin
strip extending in front of the
photographer
either side are domestic properties
which also have trees within them and
forms part of that wider landscape feel
in an officer opinion
to the right-hand side is one of the
made
or unmade tracks within hardy board
gaining giving access to the residential
properties
thanks nikki
and then you can see these photographs
have been submitted by
um one of the owners of the award who
was due to speak to you this afternoon
and this again shows the nature of the
area that
is subject to the order it's between the
hedge on the left-hand side
and the hedge on the right-hand side but
again it does exemplify that the trees
that are
located within the area are of a and
certainly an office opinion a mature
form thanks nikki
we do have a variety chair just ask
nikki to skip through these but they do
show the trees that are currently and
protected by the order between the the
fence and the hedge
thank so sticky thank you
thank you chair
thank you adrian and we have
one speaker which is an objector and
it's an amanda holden
mrs holden are you with us i am
i am can't see you i'm afraid oh
i'm gone i'm here sorry
right good afternoon and thank you chair
thank you for this opportunity
so i'm not going to repeat the reference
the representations in the report as
they can be viewed
obviously you've seen the photographs um
would have liked
a site visit because there is actually a
track
um down there um that
would have been like a natural track
that has been used many many years ago
um and it's that that we're trying to
get that is our only access into the
wood
so it would just be the clearing and
avoiding
clearing any trees um but obviously
there may be some
to get our access in there because we
haven't got any access at the moment um
the 20 foot width mentioned
in our report um has been taken from our
deeds and they are joining neighbours ds
but quite honestly you know we just
require a sympathetic track
wide enough for our vehicles any
maintenance vehicles
and of course emergency vehicles whilst
minimizing any reduction
totally understand the reasoning that
trees do provide the immunity i mean
you know we've purchased woodland with a
tp are already on there
but the track hasn't at the moment while
it didn't have the tpo
however um there are a few trees that
are
obstructing the way and these are on
this private track and a few of them
are viewed by the neighbours and
ourselves most of it is undergrowth
that's sort of causing a physical
barrier there
we are very supportive of the
surrounding communities community
you know we've provided a walkway at the
other side of our woodland so that
people can continue
you know the surrounding community can
continue to use that going from middle
road to bottle road
both the woodland and the track are in
urgent need of some management and they
could be causing a detriment
to wildlife and the environment my
husband's an avid wildlife enthusiast
with both members of the wildlife trust
and woodland owners groups
we're strongly aware that there should
be a greater amount of wildlife in there
we know how to create that habit habitat
and we've actually got more precious
wildlife on our garden in clay crosston
is in the woodland you know that's quite
neglected
it's known that the creation of rides on
access routes will open up woodland to
sunlight
which allows the flora and fauna to
thrive ball and trees
um will create a better habitat
for a wider array of wildlife too whilst
enhancing the
biodiversity of the woodland secondary
as mentioned we're more than willing to
work alongside professionals
and expand our knowledge we're just
aware and concerned that this tpo
will render our woodland our lovely you
know piece of land
landlocked and the the condition at the
moment is quite hazardous
um and it's just a way for my husband to
to go into end his working life really
and his retirement there and all of us
so
thank you thank you for listening thank
you
i have a couple of questions before i
open it to the
panel it's got down here that you're the
owner of the wood
you own part of the wood because it's
multiple ownership isn't it
yeah we own where it says the w1
our our woodland is down there however
the track
um that we're talking about is owned by
the neighbours either side because in
hardwood wood it's not adopted by the
highways
everybody owns to the middle of the road
as a way to preserve the roads to look
after the roads
so it's actually our access that we
don't own
that road that that track should say
it is the only access to our woodland
you say it's the only access but um it
does stay earlier that you
actually put a fence and gate and you
use the access from
bottom road what we did there was on
bottom road
um there is an end property brooklands
and they were having some work done
at the in their land they were having
some work done so we actually
they allowed us because they were having
a lot of work done near the woodland
and we were using the same contractor
they allowed us to let
the contract come from their land onto
the woodland
so we there is no access from bottom
road we actually used
or quite kindly these people that own
the land
allowed our contracts to come over
obviously they've since had
all this work done and they don't want
you know they don't want to contract to
going over there any further now
so it wasn't it isn't access we've used
with you
somebody else's land with their
permission
okay that's fine and my last point is if
i'm
correcting this in 2019
um some owners along the track did
actually
object to any work being carried out
down there
and in doing so they took legal advice
and you were notified of this advice
and it's regarding the rule of
perpetuity
and one of the owners has actually said
that you have no legal right of access
across there
is that correct that is not correct no
there is actually what
would need to probably happen is
it's a bit of a table tennis game at the
moment our solicitors
our legal people from our deeds and
everything else are saying we do have
access
we purchased the wood with that being
our access
and they of course are saying we haven't
got access
um that would probably need further
you know i don't know how it goes but it
is a bit of a table tennis game at the
moment
between our solicitor saying we have got
access
and their solicitor saying that we
haven't got access
okay thank you councillor foster i saw
your hand was up
uh thank you chair i'm mark foster uh
councillor for coal aston
uh hello mrs holden hello uh questions
i've got
one is uh the the access lien you're
looking for or the trike
where did the 20 foot come from where
did that original figure come from
and then uh what would the track be made
of what are you thinking of actually
putting down there
um what surface um
and last one uh further onto your own
woods that you own
have you got any plans at the minute for
any other sort of development
at all right so the 20 fort
on our deeds and the surrounding areas
where the track is that we're discussing
it's actually a horseshoe
shape around the woodlands and it was
on the d's it says intended roads and it
was 20
it's actually written down as 20 foot
wide
with borders of eight for either side so
that's
where the 24 originally came from
however 24 is a is
quite a width and a lot wider than
getting one vehicle down there which is
you know
if it meant we could get a vehicle down
there would be absolutely
brilliant definitely not the 20 foot
um what was the other one sorry the 20
foot i can't hear you i think you're
muted
you're beautiful sorry yeah my apologies
uh what was it made of the track is it
wood road ash felt hard
well the track i think people have said
probably was used 1960s so i don't know
what was down there
so at the moment it's just you can
actually see
vaguely see there was a track but the
road there isn't anything down there
we would just want something just a
surface
just to casually be able to go up and
down with our vehicles
so whatever anybody to do
this we would obviously ask advice i
mean we've already been in touch with a
um anderson tree care so we would ask
advice
for the most sympathetic the least
disturbing way that we could put a track
down
so anything like that we haven't
we haven't decided on a track yet any
material for a track yet
so and the last one was
do you have any further plans down there
for any sort of development at all
no no i mean it's basically you know
we've got
four grandchildren another one on the
way they're very tiny
um i always worked with early years so i
know
how much you know they benefit from
woodland
my husband it's i think it's a project
really it's a project for us
a nature project you know we've always
wanted what a woodland he's always
wanted a woodland
well the call emblem in ray mears or
percy thrower
you know he just loves his wildlife and
it would be
somewhere we could go to we only live in
clay cross
somewhere we can travel to and spend our
time there there's a stream beautiful
stream running through it
and it's just just to enjoy the peace
the peace
and the nature you know and that's
that's the way
we want to go something for us and the
family
any other questions
counselor elliot councillor thank you
chad
and yeah if you could just indulge me
for
for one moment if that woodland is
actually sort of landlocked
why would you need access with vehicles
to it as opposed to going down and
enjoying as you've just said the peace
and tranquility of it
because it's it's to start with it's
quite a long track
and also within hardwood wood
um like i said before all the roads are
owned by the landowners so
unfortunately the times that we have
tried to park within hardwood wood to
then
walk down to the track um you're
constantly told that you're actually
trespassing
because they do own the roads it's not
um what is it highways um it's an
adopted road
yeah they're all they're all unadopted
yeah so actually wherever you park and
we're quiet away
in the wood as well so we've got a long
journey into the wood
you kind of try and park near the ward
you're always parking on somebody's land
and obviously they you know they come
out and tell you that that you're
parking on their land kind of thing
then it is quite it is quite a long
track to then
walk down and get down you know you've
got your rucksacks and everything
so it is limited it is limiting
what we can do in there what we want
just to go in there and enjoy it to take
things in
to trim areas you know even just to take
a picnic in
to to kind of build a shelter or
anything like that it's limiting
that kind of thing you know and that's
that's what it's doing we can't park
anywhere
to you know the actual if we could just
get off the wood
off the access and onto our land to be
able to park a vehicle
then you know that would be great and
did you did you know this when you
purchased the land and how long have you
had it
when oh gosh we've had it a few years
now so when we purchased it there's
two lots of land that we've we've
purchased and the first well both pieces
of land
when we purchased them over this
obviously the first piece we were told
that was our access yes they used to do
it they
they used to use it the second piece
that is right next to it
um the gentleman that's been in his
family since 1946 his father owned it
and they used to use it to go for
picnics they knew of somebody that
i think used to live um obviously it
must have been like a nissan hut or
something on some footings in our land
um you know they we've even been told
they used to use it so
obviously we knew there'd got to be some
work to
either create a track um because it was
all overgrown
but we didn't realize that there would
be such
objection we weren't you know we were
told that yeah that was our access
and we knew that financially we'd got to
do some work on that access
but that was part of you know buying it
that that isn't the issue okay thank you
thank you any other questions
oh mo sorry yes you're on my list
thank you um mrs told them my question
is relating to
the option that would already be
available to you as in
um applying to undertake the works as an
and
and and when necessary um on an
individual basis
as detailed in section 2.4
can you just tell us why that option
wouldn't work for you
please i think it i mean it would work
um i think it's more of a
sort of the more work i've done and gone
into it i think i've probably read
quite a few scaremongering things that
once the tpo is on
obviously you know it can prevent you
doing so many things and i think it's
that sort of thing that's frightening
it definitely is it is an option
um but it's it's a bit of a scary
option i mean at the moment it's it's an
option that i probably haven't
you know when you think about it i it
needs to be done it's
i think it's just the restriction i'm
frightened of the restriction
and being told that i can't access my
land
you know it's that that kind of thing
and just thinking that milan's going to
be lying locked
you know you there's quite a few things
that i've read into where
possibly this has happened or it's been
a bit of a fight it's it's just that
that is the frightening thing
oh any further questions counselor
shipment
and um it's just kind of what you you
said earlier
presumably you're you're letting anybody
enjoy your life
now what it is there's a it's a track
that goes down
the other side what we've managed to do
is fence an area
um because i mean it was quite a
free-for-all
so what we did we fenced off an area and
then there was
everybody sort of always walked um from
one road to another in there
so what we did is where the track was
we made sure we didn't fence over that
track we sort of kept that track so
people
can still go up and down that track can
still carry on with that
so that's what we did there
thank you any other questions
nope thank you very much mrs holden
thank you
[Music]
right thank you now we're going to have
questions for
adrian councillor foster
thank you chair uh question for adrian
um
we've we've heard uh the applicant say
it's quite a long trike
do you know and i know there's big trees
small trees medium sized trees i've got
all of that but could give you
give me a rougher approximation of how
many trees there are
of different sizes just roughly please
i'm i'm i'm allowed to do that it would
just purely simply be a guess
um there are a considerable number of
trees within the
rectangular area that are of significant
size
but any number would be a complete case
i've not
surveyed them to that extent i'm afraid
i think the photographs
do show the area in
in an appropriate way though it's it's
not as if there are just one or two
trees within there they are significant
trees and they all
are all along the area that is currently
the subject of the order i'm sorry i
can't help further chair but
it would be a would be a complete guess
i'm afraid
i i appreciate that i knew it would be a
difficult question mr kirk and do you
know roughly how long this
area is how long the this thin recta
rectangle is i
don't know if i've missed that on the
documents um you've not uh and again
i've not put those measurements in the
in the um the detailing i would i would
have said it's
um three or four hundred meters long
it's a when um when i've walked it it
did take
a while to to get through it it's very
overgrown and
brambles as well which make navigating
it difficult it is quite a significant
length um i'm sorry i don't know exactly
what i would have said it's
it's getting off that sort of length
thank you
any other questions for agent
councillor elliot
yeah hey adrian do you think this
would be um in your opinion
would it be viable to to build something
down there
is is that you know the potential of
putting a track into it
there is absolutely room to put a track
in there it's the impact of that
on on trees which i i couldn't quantify
without knowing the detail
it's certainly wide enough for example
to get a land rover and trailer in
the area is wide as you would have seen
in photographs when scaling it up
against the size of the gentleman who
was walking down there
it is able to do that but of course if
you
confirm the order the the making of that
track
would itself either require consent or
the removal of the trees to facilitate
access
would require consent i think as
councilor potts um
was asking mrs holden if you are to
confirm the order it doesn't necessarily
mean
that an application can't be submitted
and can't be approved it just needs to
go through that process which does
add an element of assessment
and uncertainty to what would otherwise
probably be
actions that could be undertaken without
any recourse to the council gives the
council control over that
but it doesn't negate that and if the
council is minded to refuse an
application
for works to treat protected by an order
then there is a right of appeal against
that so it's the
making of an order doesn't preclude
those other actions but of course it
puts in those checks
and balances which may not exist at the
present time the other thing that
is applicable to to this order and the
next item that you'll be considering is
both
are woodland orders and there is
the provision that the forestry
commission has to agree management
proposals for woodland
areas that are otherwise protected by
tree preservation orders that
override any formal protection that the
council has although we are consulted on
those
proposals if the area of london is
that there is a suggestion that maybe
for areas only over three hectares or
more
therefore if it isn't applicable for a
forestry commission woodland management
scheme
there are provisions within the
regulations that application can be made
to the council
something similar that allows for
ongoing management and maintenance
on a yearly or or more regular basis
that can be done without
having ongoing applications needing to
be submitted so that is another
option that's open to those who own
woodlands that are protected by
tree preservation orders preventing the
need necessarily to come back every time
you want to
chop back a twig or a branch or rent to
get undertake
proper arboricultural management areas
yeah sorry rather a rather a long long
answer to casually a simple question
chair
no it it's a great answer adrian i've
worked down there more times than i
could shake a stick out and i like the i
like the
feel of it because it's it's still
fairly natural and it's not run with all
hard surfaces
other than you know a few a few small
bits what i'm loath to
to do is put a huge wide tarmac track
down into a wood
and and all the things that go with it
but
yeah thanks for your answer agent at
least it gives me a bit more insight
counselor barry yeah adrian i've heard
talk about the neighbors around and who
owns what
and what have you have they been
consulted on this do they
have the right to put their penny's
worth in
or for their comments to be heard um or
is it
treated differently because it's trees
we're talking about and not
a building there is no regulation that
requires consultation
on issues such as this is not a planning
application you're being asked to
consider
but what we have done as we're required
to do
is to consult with all those who own or
have an interest in the land
and sort any comments from those parties
if we've had comments from them they are
reported to you either
in the report or in the late
representations
and in those instances where we received
them early enough they were invited to
speak
what we've not done though we've not
gone out as we would with a planning
application
and sought comment from potentially
other interested parties
thank you are there any other questions
no thank you adrian i'm going to open
the floor
for debate just a reminder that please
no motions until we've all had to say
does anyone want to open the floor
councillor shipment um this one seems
like a new brand to me we've got
somebody that's got
a better land that seems to be
safeguarding these trees for the future
um and they just need to make it easier
so they can
access it and maintain it for me it's
it's you know it's gonna have better
quality
vegetation and trees within it if they
maintain properly how often do we see
trees coming in it's like well let's
chop them down because they're dead and
they're not looked after
there's an application to exactly the
opposite to what we usually see
um and for me i think we um
and he's passing
councillor barry councillor foster um
i think for me i'm i'm more on the lines
of sticking with what officers are
saying but having like a management
um plan which is what adrian alluded to
earlier on in order that the
the woods are preserved as they are like
you said it doesn't stop them from
actually applying
to do any changes but it just gives that
little bit more protection to the woods
themselves so i think for me
personally i'd rather stay on that track
i think the officers are going down the
right route
thank you councillor foster uh thank you
chair i'm inclined to agree with
councillor barry and i think it's a no
brainer much like ross
uh castle shipman said i think it's a no
brainer but the opposite
way we've got 200 yards by 20 foot
that's a lot of trees to me
these trees aren't diseased uh they're
not dead and
um just for access so you can take a
vehicle down here
i'm not inclined to agree that the uh
that we should let them be cut down
because once that tpo is off them uh you
can chop those trees down
uh we've argued lots and lots here
about tpos previously and we've even
we've even numbered the trees there's
this many trees how about we cut down
that many trees and i think it was
something you were interested
uh council shipments in your area before
and we argued about each particular tree
this one's disease this one's not
we replace it with this one or that one
or a different type of tree we went into
that detail
here we haven't gone into any sort of
detail other than it's 20 foot wide and
200 yards long and it's a lot of trees
that aren't nobody's mentioned diseased
or anything
so there's a lot of trees about to be uh
given we'll give permission for them to
be taken down
if we don't continue with the uh
preservation order
as it stands and as and as he's
recommended so for me i think it is a
no-brainer there's a lot of trees here
we don't know the number
and they need protecting and it needs to
continue uh
and lastly page 82 uh there's a bit of a
nonsense in there
about taking emergency vehicles down
there you don't take
18 ton fire engines down the track
doesn't happen
uh you know if there's a fire in the
woods you take betas you do not take 18
ton
fire engines so i don't know how that
got in um
but that's something to definitely to be
ignored so for myself
i support uh not propose anything but i
support what officers have put forward
no brainer for me thank you thank you i
also
have to agree with councillor barry and
councillor foster
and the officer's recommendation
i know a lot of history regarding
hardwick wood this used to be my award
and the other thing we should look at
too here
this wood has the most fantastic
wildlife
they've got deers they've got badgers
they've got foxes they all come into
their gardens
the minute you start ripping this up
that'll all change
so to me it is a no-brainer we keep the
tpos that those goods should remain as
they are
thank you
any other questions comments
thank you we'll move to emotion and i
think believe counselor barry has a
motion to put forward
well really it's just to move officers
recommendations
and go for what they've stated and i'll
second that
is everyone happy with that so that's
the confirmation then
of the provisional um tree preservation
order is that the essence of a chair
yes we could also conditionally put in
there if possible that there is a
maintenance
um contract or section in there
if i may share and that would if you can
vote to confirm the order then that
would come following that
from the owner of the award or the
proposal of the management order by way
of formal application so
members then get the chance to consider
that it would be similar to a
an application to do works to trees as
you will have seen have been consulted
on many times
but it would as it is a woodland order
it would contain
a schedule of ongoing maintenance that
you could then
and consider and if acceptable approve
which would then
as i say negate the need to come back
for every minor element of works that
may be required on an annual basis but
that wouldn't
form part of this resolution check you
might need to confirm the order
that is a decision in itself any
subsequent management would conform
would come forward as part of an
application subsequently
thank you is everyone happy with that
okay councillor shipman yeah i just want
to clarify so
agent are you saying that you the
applicant would
would only have to come back once a year
with a plan for the
for the following year as to what
they're planning to do
with the trees and let's say if they
wanted to throw a path
put the road in that would be a separate
application to that as well
i believe that is exactly what i'm
saying yes if they wanted to take trees
out as a one-off
and i think that would form part of an
application itself that would be form
part
properly of a proposal to put an area
into there that would
allow for a track ongoing management
maintenance i think would be a separate
consideration which would then allow for
ongoing
management and maintenance award on an
ongoing basis but that would then
not come back every year but it would
allow for example
annual maintenance you would expect in
any well-managed problem
right okay i think you might have been a
bit confused to be honest then on that
one
i apologize chair if i've confused you
okay that's clear now right
so alan if you'd just like to read the
motion right
so just in terms of that can i just get
confirmation as to who's moved and
seconded this
councilor barry moved it and i second it
okay thank you
so um as i understand it the motion is
to
uh confirm the tree preservation order
uh along the lines that set out in the
report
yes thank you all right we'll take a
vote on it now thank you nikki
thank you uh members um as per previous
votes if you clearly indicate
fought against or abstain
thank you thank you everyone we can move
on to
a gender item eight
and again this is a tpo at drum field
trees that
gossamell lane i think i've pronounced
that right apologies if i haven't
and i'm going to ask adrian are you
leading on this one as well
yes thank you chair thomas elaine at
tron field it's similar
in detail to item seven share this
is a report seeking members views on
whether or not to confirm the
provisional tpo
275 made on a wood of trees this time in
tron field
these trees chair are constrained by
developed on all sides as we'll see in a
second and were originally identified
for attention
and approval was granted for a small
area of housing on the area of land to
the west of the wood again we'll see
that in a second
in this case chair officers consider the
trees do offer
amenity value in terms of their visual
presence within an otherwise urban
landscape
but also in this instance they offer an
element of
ecological interest that they support
and as is set out in the representations
before members and as set out in the
late reps and particularly
the comments made from the derbyshire
and badger
group and also the darshan wildlife
trust concern has been raised chair by
various parties that ongoing maintenance
management of the world may be
prejudiced by a tpo
as we've just discussed chen in the
report and i've suggested that agreement
with the forestry commission may allow
ongoing management actually it's not
actually
as clear because i think that may only
reflect on what's
more than three hectares in size as i've
said where that doesn't stop
but the methods of securing ongoing
management would avoid the need to come
back
on recurring occasions for applications
and consent to
undertake ongoing management such as
treating back woods
overhang gardens for example as such
chair again officers consider that the
ward offers importance of entry value to
the area
i recommend that the tpo is confirmed in
its unmodified form
thank you chair let's go through the uh
at the slides if nikki can
thanks nikki
as you can see the the area of concern
here is the area that's
the center of the slide w1 and just to
the
west of there there's the small
development of high dale fold which was
granted consent on the provider at that
time this area of woodland was retained
for its amenity and ecological value as
you can see the site is surrounded by an
otherwise urban environment of
residential properties
thanks nikki
this is a few photographs showing the
wood and their relationship to the
houses nearby on the right hand side
here you can see high dale fold and the
arif housing
then the trees beyond that are the trees
that form this area
not the beach hedge in the foreground
but the trees behind them
that you can then see behind the houses
and there's two other photographs along
gumrosau lane
taken from where that blue van is parked
looking at the woodland behind
the wall there thanks nikki
and again and then i think there are a
couple of photographs taken from oh
sorry
next one nikki please from both sides of
netherdean
road i think it is never deemed close
and just go back one please nikki
um you can see the woodland in the
middle distance at the end of netherdine
and then the other one nikki please you
can go on one
this shows it from the west looking back
towards heidel fall there the house is
in the
middle of the slide the um greyer tinged
houses and then again you can see the
woodland
behind there that forms the subject of
the report
i think that's it thank you
thank you and we'll move on to
the first speaker for this and it's the
objector and the wood owner fraser allen
mr allen are you there
mr allen hello hi
can't see you mr allen i can hear you
but i can't one second
i can see you now
let's hear me now yep you have three
minutes when you're ready
right thank you um i've received copies
from various supporters
of the letters from objectors and
supporters of tpo
and i'd just like to comment that first
like no trees have been filled in the
woodland or removed
some of the trees we were taught by a
professional tree surgeon um
the back part of last year after this
was done after they've been
done a visual inspection beforehand and
the trees that are purchased and planted
were mature evergreen
uh ireland's neville stephen hollis that
produced
um lots of berries last winter for the
wildlife
and and the laurel bushes that
perches are planted on the edge of the
wood where it meets the end of nether
dean road
purely to improve the aesthetic look for
the neighboring houses one of the
residents on another dean even commented
100 times better in addition to this i'm
currently purchasing further trees to
plant in clear areas of the woodland
i previously stated many times in
writing to the council the reason for
the purchase was to protect and prevent
the woodland from being disturbed
to further protect the wildlife's
natural habitat so i feel this is
paramount to everybody
the woodland additionally acts as
privacy to mine and many other
neighboring properties
have no intention of any kind to develop
the woodland
i am fully aware of the values of the
woodland and the wildlife within it
hence wanting to improve in accordance
with good horticultural practice
and woodland management i am actually
not objecting
to the tpo being placed on the wood
my only objection was the planning
department's lack of willingness to
consider
confirming with with a modification in
my opinion
allowing the boundary pruning especially
to neighboring properties should not be
an issue
some of the letters the council has
received report supports this
should the tpo be enforced without this
modification not only will they have
reports enough to apply to the council
a permission to bring back any trees
they should wish to do so
but also myself as the owner of the
woodland should they require to cut back
beyond the boundary
in anticipation of them hanging over a
few weeks later
listening to the previous tpo order
i've now been enlightened to the fact
that i can now
apply for the management and maintenance
to to obtain one of those which would
actually
cover that problem for me by giving me
the ability to prune them back if that
was if that was agreed
and i stated previously i'm more than
willing to work with the council
trees preservation officer and discuss
the woodland and how it best be managed
and maintained
and one of the letters from a neighbor
on ideal fault state are working
competitions
seconds remain thank you um
i do work in construction but i'm not a
principal contractor and i'm not in the
house building sector
there's some kind of observed amount of
belief was my intention to develop the
woodland especially from a gentleman
living on methadene road
who requested the tpu in the first place
again i have no intention of developing
them
i feel some some would rather comment
and complain to the council to try to
achieve the prevention of something
that's not going to exist
the development of the woodland their
their time and effort would be far more
beneficial to the woodlands in this
wildlife if they're channeling
it's time to change instead of
being the ones that have possibly
causing clearly
to further deteriorate thank you thank
you
are there any questions for mr owen
no okay thank you very much mr owen
we have one supporter and that's a cath
lewis
to speak
hello hey you have three minutes when
you're ready
okay can't see you now you've dropped
off completely
oh no that's okay we can hear you so
carry on
okay sorry about that um
yeah i'm in full agreement with the
recommendations of the officer report
to confirm the tpo without modification
and the trees form precious isolated
green woodland
among harsh urban sprawl over a dozen
different species of trees make up the
woodland
the trees and plants within woodland are
bustling with wildlife
and they provide essential habitat for
countless
insects birds mammals amphibians um
we feel privileged uh living next to the
woods
listening to the dawn chorus roosting
calls of the birds
catching the badges on nightcam and
seeing the bats go to roost and it's
it's
lovely to live there and have the
woodland
and it's without doubt achieving its
purpose of providing
a thriving wildlife easement area and
the trees are fundamental in achieving
this
of course the trees in the woodland need
effective management but the management
needs to be in sync
and with center with sensitivity towards
the wildlife
and sadly the woodland management over
recent years has caused me concerns and
the trees were pruned in
high to nesting season and there's been
some house built
in the ward and the garden sheds
appeared there since
um and that was done without planning
permission
originally and by reading the tpo
information it's clear to me that the
tpo legislation promotes good
woodland management which is what's
needed and surely an organized and
considered approach from the landowner
working collaboratively with woodland
specialists and the local authority
will only enhance the woodland
management rather than severely hinder
it
um in summary i believe that the trees
are worthy of investment and safeguard
afforded
by the tpo in fact it's quite possibly
the only means to ensure the longevity
of the thriving woodland habitat
without the tpo what measure is there to
prevent any owner of the land from
felling the trees
not just this owner we need to
preserve the the longevity of the wood
thank you thank you are there any
questions
no thank you very much okay are there
any questions
for the planning officer
oh sorry i do business i'm looking at
the list i've
got
are there many more speakers as rebecca
uh rebecca robustas
um um sort of had to pull out chair uh
she's unable to attend the meeting
but her speaking text uh that happened
very very um
shortly before the meeting started but a
text is
in the uh document pack which members
have received
okay thank you so moving on then are
there any
counsellor foster uh yeah
question for officers mr kirkham um
if you can run uh run me through uh
again the
what can be done to support the works
that um
the owner of the woods uh needs to do
where we could confirm the tpo as per
recommendations
but satisfy um through a management
program
um the owner's request to be able to
trim the woods and the boundary
could you run me through uh that again
please
certainly yeah if my um understanding
is that the forestry commission
management scheme to only include
woodland of three hectares or more this
area of woodland wouldn't be caught by
that
it the guidance isn't specific but i
think the comments that mr allen has
made
to me subsequently would be made may
actually be that that is the correct
interpretation of the guidance the
alternative of that is that there is
provision made out
within the regulations in the practice
guidance
that application so it needs to be in
form of an application
that application can be made to the
council
to set out for a woodland tpo
ongoing management and maintenance of
that would so for example in this case
representation's been submitted that
those surrounding the woodland are
concerned that they can't
trim back branches on yearly growth for
example so
mr allen or somebody else could make an
application if the order's confirmed
to say that every year we will cut back
the branches that overhang neighboring
gardens by
taking it in a meter from the boundary
for example
and we will also wish to clear out
understory of
branches or tweaks
and i'm not saying this is the way the
application before but
for example it could say we will clear
out every year branches twigs
lower than two meters in height or
patrice
of the tree stem for example so clearly
understory so it would set out a
management
program that would be done then on an
annual basis
so that it would avoid the need for
every year for mr allen
the owner of the wood or anyone else to
come forward with a new application go
through the new process
and it would allow then ongoing
maintenance management of the ward
that would need to be formed in the form
of an application
so it wouldn't just be something that's
agreed outside the public
process of how applications are
considered and members would have the
chance to comment on that
as and when it was submitted but if
granted it would then
avoid the need for every time that the
owner of the wood or
somebody who had a trio bang their
boundary wanted to trim back a branch by
a couple of inches
in theory had to come into the council
for consent for that
so it would take the form of a
management and
maintenance program it would need to be
properly set out
but if approved it would then allow for
the proper ongoing management and
maintenance of that award and that could
be contained
within an application avoiding ongoing
applications that would otherwise need
to be submitted
i i do hope that's helpful channel
explains the situation to members
clearly
that's fine thank you mr kirkland thank
you councillor barry
yeah it's still on the same thing um
really
so when when one of these applications
are made
um it could be stipulated that you you
don't trim
trees at a certain time of the year due
to the nesting and that
that sort of thing is that this sort of
management style that you'd be looking
at as to
you've mentioned about you know cutting
off lower branches or whatever
but i take it we could put in there
about the nesting season and so on and
so forth about the wildlife that's in
there
we could and we would expect a well
set out management plan to be aware of
that you would normally undertake works
to trees
within the winter months in any case
to avoid undertaking which under
someone's when the tree is growing
that's poor of our cultural management
but of course anything that is contained
within the tpo doesn't take away the
um law that protects birds nesting birds
and other mammals in any case it
wouldn't override that
but yes we would expect a management
plan
to set out works that were done normally
between november
the very latest the end of march when
you would normally undertake your
management plan that your management
works
thank you are there any other questions
no thank you adrian okay we can move on
to the next bit i can open it up for
debate
yeah i think this particular application
very similar to the previous one um
for me is that it's we go along with the
officers recommendations
and then it applies for um
a management plan on an annual basis
councillor foster then councillor
richway
thanks for that chair um yeah i'm
thinking exactly
along those lines that um i'm not
proposing anything yet but i would like
to
as it's an area i live in myself so i
i'd like to be part of the uh
uh proposing that we we take on this tpo
i know from other councillors that
represent this area because uh two of
them have
fed their comments on to me about this
and also
it's in line with our neighborhood plan
in dromfield where we protect
uh we've got it in there to connect
trees
we've also got it uh we've also in in
dronefield as a town council
plant many trees around the different
parks and the different
areas jackman there's there's clearly
something going on
um good is everyone
mike yes that's it i think sure yeah
thanks for that uh yeah uh the town
council plant many trees
around in the different parks uh and the
different pieces of land we owe and
we've also got tree planting
projects where we give trees to
residents so we're very much in favor of
protecting trees in drumfield
so i'd be supportive of of this uh
that the tpos were uh were kept on it
and that we invited
a management and maintenance program
from mr allen
uh where he's able to trim and look
after his uh
property uh his trees on an annual basis
so when it comes to it i'd like to
propose that thank you chair
thank you councillor ridgeway uh yeah i
was going to go along the same lines as
um councillor barry and councillor
foster
and i hope that it's not just wrongfield
that um
give their residents and look after
trees and that's i hope it's everywhere
in in this area but
yeah i'll go along with it
you any other comments just as a point
of clarity on that chair
uh just a point of explanation for
council of ridgeway uh it is just
dronfield at the minute that gives free
trees away
it's something we do as a town council
so it's not something that happens all
over the country we do it here
i hope that helps thank you councillor
shipman
yeah uh i can't are we creating a new
tpo here or are we amending an existing
one because the
the packs say we created a new one and
council fosters just said we
were changing the existing one
i just want to understand are we
creating a brand new tpo on this line if
so
isn't that separate from the management
aspect you were talking about
the report before members this afternoon
chair
is seeking members views on whether to
confirm or not recreational tpo that's
been made
if it is confirmed then
if mr allen wished to make application
in the form of an ongoing maintenance
management plan that would form part of
a standalone application
that would then be considered as per
applications are so there would be
public consultation members would be
consorted parish council consulted etc
and the decision taken so there's two
processes going on here first of all a
provisional order has been made and the
decision suffering from members is
whether or not to confirm that
if it is confirmed works to trees within
the are so protected would need to gain
the consent of the council
in this instance that could form part of
an application
that includes an ongoing maintenance
management plan
so just to close so so in terms of the
last one the last one was to
change the tpo that was already on the
water wasn't it
again with the 272 in hardwood wood that
likewise that was
where the members wanted to confirm the
provisional order
and the decision has been taken this
afternoon to confirm that order
unmodified
so that order will be confirmed in line
with
members resolution if in that instance
mrs holden or anyone else who owns that
wood
wishes to make applications to undertake
ongoing maintenance and management they
too would have to submit
an application additionally you ask the
question for the other
the other side if they wish to
provide a track into the wood if that
included development that would form
part of a
proper planning application that if
granted
would allow for the removal any trees
that got in the way of that built
development
but could include provision for removal
of trees to form that
track in any case this is getting a bit
more complicated than
just the report chair so i hope that's
helpful if there is any further
clarification
i'm happy to provide that but in the
case of the track that would be
development
so that would require plenty consent in
its own right
probably but as
as i'm sure all members know if
permission is granted for development
and that
includes the removal of trees otherwise
protected with that being a conservation
area or by tpo
that development permission allows for
the removal of any
trees otherwise protected without other
consent
so that overrides so if you've got a
your back gardens covered in trees
protected by an order and the council
granted consent
grants you consent to build a house
there you can then remove the
trees reasonably necessary to build a
house
right thank you i think that's all as
clear right
any more questions for adrian
no thank you okay i shall open the
floor now councillor foster
which as i said before i'd like to go
along and propose that we accept
officers
recommendations in confirming this tpo
and at the same time inviting mr allen
uh
to apply for a management and
maintenance program
and i'll second that yeah councillor pal
if also could before continue uh yeah uh
perhaps uh
if if council eliot might allow perhaps
invite uh
councillor powell who's the uh one
member for that area perhaps he'd like
to consider
being part of this if ms sterling didn't
mind it's just a planning committee mark
it's not about getting points from what
you want is it
let's do it then peter let's do it let's
do it
yeah councillor powell you had your hand
up to speak uh i was going to second
[ __ ]
okay thank you so we we've had the
motion put in by councillor foster it
was seconded by councillor elliot
and so the motion that uh is to a prove
um or confirm the um
provisional tpo along the line set out
in the report so that is unamended
and then i our members also asking for a
second strand to that
which actually says that mr um
sort of um alan be
urged or sort of informed of is um that
he could apply for a suitable management
order
council foster you happy with that
that's fine
thank you all right can we have a show
up
off you go nikki thank you chair
um commemorative fought against her
abstain casper armitage
paul kelsey barry
oh council ridgeway
four cancer rouse or
casa rough four cancer shipment
or chad that's 12 votes four
zero against zero abstentions is
unanimously carried
thank you all thank you for that and we
move on to agenda item nine
which is the planning appeals lodged and
determined
another one for you adrian
not a great deal to to raise with
members chad has just been the one
decision
reported that was an appeal that's been
dismissed but
it is perhaps appropriate to to outline
the ongoing
stream of appeals that we're getting in
at the moment and it does
share causes um
it takes a lot of resource to administer
these
these appeals so we're dealing with that
at the moment as we go forwards but
i'm sure that we've had there's four
more
appeals that are in the the ashgate
property developments
it's an informal view that's taking
place shortly the scout group at
homes field and the crossbar
chest field and the sickle house hemi
green they're all
going we've just submitted information
to the inspectors on those
and last week we did receive three more
appeals chair which were reported in due
course
thank you take any questions any comment
questions no
thank you all very much it's been a long
day long afternoon but thank you for
your forbearance and i wish you all good
night okay thank you
you